one minute till showtime
good morning everyone and welcome to the
march 1st session
of the science technology and energy
committee i hope everybody is feeling
good today we had a great day yesterday
and i anticipate another good day today
our purpose today is to
[Music]
execute executive sessions on 10
different bills
and once we complete those 10 bills
we will be almost done
as you'll recall from yesterday we did
recess
the exec session on house bill 1459
and i have rescheduled
the resumed executive session for monday
march 7th
at 10 a.m
so we will resume that executive session
on monday march 7th at 10 a.m and when
we finish that executive session we will
be done with house bills
for
2022.
we will then await crossover which
happens at the end of march and we will
start hearing senate bills at that time
i have been told by the clerk that it
may be possible for us to start hearing
senate bills even before crossover so
i'm hoping that we can make that happen
so that we don't have a
three plus week period where we sit
around and do nothing
now because we're coming back here on
monday march 7th for the resumed
executive session on hb 1459
and since some of us have to make a
fairly long trip to get here
i'm trying to arrange another activity
for that day the
eversource arborist
would like to come and give us a
presentation on what eversource does
for vegetation management along their
transmission and distribution lines
so
we're right now discussing whether they
will come at nine o'clock or at eleven
o'clock
one side or the other of the executive
session so
as soon as we pin that down i will let
everyone know but you can plan on being
here for
the
presentation by the arborist from
eversource
on that day as well as the executive
session for
h.b 14 59
so before we go any farther we need to
all rise and join representative mann as
he leads us in the pledge of allegiance
to the flag of the united states
thank you before we get started this
morning we have to point out that we
have some
substitute members amongst our number
once again substituting for
representative samsich is representative
linda massamia
thank you for being here representative
representative vincent is also out again
today and today we have representative
horrigan
substituting for
representative vincent
and representative christian couldn't be
with us today so
representative
hacken phillips mary hacken phillips is
substituting today so i issue a
hearty welcome to all of you nice to
have you here and we look forward to the
rest of our day mr chair
representative thomas thank you
it looks like we may have a little bit
of time in the month of march
and once we get through our last bill
i will look at
one or two dates
preferably a tuesday that we might be
able to fit in a tour with the
concurrence of the
of the speaker so um i will get back to
you on what we can see what we can do if
the
anyone who wants to join can do it and
what
i'm not sure yet let me uh we gotta find
out who will accept this for one thing
and what the speaker will allow make it
warm
it won't be a tour to florida no
unfortunately sorry about that
the possibilities are seabrook the
nuclear plant in seabrook there's some a
couple of hydro power stations that we
might be able to do a tour of
iso new england is a possibility so
there are several different
possibilities
thank you representative thomas
so we have a schedule for today we've
got 10 bills on the agenda
we are going to have to move some
however
the published agenda shows hb 1258 as
being the last bill of the day that's
actually now going to be the first bill
of the day
and the reason for that is because the
department of energy
is uh
very busy and in order for them to have
representatives here this morning who
could answer questions
they requested that we move that bill to
first on the agenda so we're going to do
that and we'll start that
executive session in just a moment
representative callie pitts just a
parliamentary question can we do that
without it being posted
24 hours yes
there's no time on any of these no time
we can do them whenever we want thank
you
the other bill that we're going to move
is house bill 1546
limiting air emissions of pluto
fluorochemicals
and the reason we're moving that bill is
because representative boyd
wanted an amendment for that bill
but
we didn't file one in a timely fashion
so that bill is act that amendment is
actually being drafted as we speak
it will be here at some point later in
the day but we're probably going to take
up that bill
right before
hb
we're having a work session at two
o'clock on hb 1645 followed by an
executive session
and that will be our last bill of the
day
so
representative notter
thank you mr chairman um today is
representative pelosi's birthday and in
celebration we have cookies and cupcakes
on the witness table and napkins so help
yourself and happy birthday
representative
thank you representative notter
any other uh stray business we need to
attend to before we get into exec
session
seeing none
i will
open the exact session on house bill
and recognize representative harrington
mr chairman i move to
accept the amendment 2022-0851h
on hb 1258
and i just want to mention again to
everybody i handed out copies of this
yesterday
and the they only copied the odd pages
so everyone should have got a
replacement one today with all the pages
thank you representative notter is
recognized
i second the motion
it's been moved and seconded that we
adopt amendment 2022-0851
h to house bill 1258 is there any
discussion
representative harrington
yes thank you mr chairman
this bill is a result of the
subcommittee and this the changes on
here are what was to agreed with by
everybody that was on the subcommittee
most of them or a lot of them are
changes where one place that says public
utilities commission now it says the
department of energy and vice versa
there were a couple of other things that
were agreed on that had to be changed
and these are uh new changes so i i
recommend people go to page 2
line
22. and
that was something that was agreed on
for the period of five years whatever
comes first that's about uh re
reviewing the rules um
and that was that was something people
decided they wanted to have in
that was one change and let me see if
you go over to
the
bottom of page 4 line 36
this was a request by the puc
and the transcripts or minutes of oral
arguments shall not constitute the final
order the final order shall include but
not be limited to and we remove the
positions of each party on each issue
again this just says it doesn't have to
be put in and typically what the puc has
done over the years is they would
summarize the positions of all the
parties put them in their order and then
they write the order basically after
that part all the positions of all the
parties are on the website and anybody
can go look them up anytime they want to
so it's really redundant to put them in
here and in fact it's a summary of
somebody else's work so i'm not sure if
it's actually that helpful but that was
a change they wanted to cut back on some
of that and there was another one
where was this
okay this was one that was kind of a
major change on the bottom of page six
line 31
this was the idea of what happens if
there was a disagreement with the how
the department of energy did the things
and there was quite a discussion over
that well then the next uh appellate um
uh body would be the
supreme court which seemed to be really
out of reach for most people and so
forth so that's why we added this and it
says if the party bringing the complaint
is unsatisfaction unsatisfied with the
disposition of the complaint and by the
department of energy they may then
petition the public utilities commission
to resolve the matter through and due to
proceedings so it gives a a method of
of doing something that's a lot easier
than filing with the supreme court
and
okay
i think most of these let me see those
were all other ones that were in there
there was was there one more over here
because there are other changes but
these were changes that were already
discussed so i'm not going to go over
every every change but those i think
were all the major ones
oh and there was in the one if you go
over to page 10
uh line 11
the employees of the commission and the
department are not otherwise prohibited
from participating in the activities of
the four motion aforementioned
organizations in which the other agency
has the lead role this gets a little
confusing because of the setup because
some of the organizations like naruto
are designed for public utilities
commissioners but they also address
regional and national issues with ferc
so
the way our
thing would be set up that would be the
department of energy would be involved
in those issues but you'd still have the
puc involved because it's nairu so on
those things they would work
collaboratively and we just
we just think they can work it out
that's one of those things we kind of
warn both groups that don't get into
silos on this but you got to work
together on this so
and that's the major changes other than
the ones you know there's a bunch of
minor ones where we change the
terminology and one last uh thing i
wanted to mention is that
this is probably not the end of this uh
reorganization paperwork
i'm sure that you know griffin will be
back here or david maybe six months or a
year from now whatever saying okay we
found five more things that need to be
changed because it really doesn't work
the way it was written so i just want to
let people know this is not the end all
of everything this is just an
incremental step towards making the
process work better
okay thank you representative harrington
representative plett thank you mr chair
thank you for taking my question
representative harrington
uh the sub there was a subcommittee on
this does this uh incorporate all of the
suggestions from the subcommittee yes it
does
well i'll accept one uh house bill 1285
which we passed yesterday was originally
going in here but somehow okay i'm sorry
i forgot that yeah we because of some
confusion over how we were going to word
that 1285 which was going to go in here
was pulled out and it was passed
separately so but you put the two
together the effect is everything the
subcommittee asked for was would be
accepted
further discussion we have um
attorney shulock from the department of
energy here to answer questions if there
are any
but um
further discussion would be the floor is
open for further discussion so
representative mcgee is recognized thank
you mr chairman yes i do have a question
and i i'm i apologize to
you may want to come up mr schumacher uh
if i had asked this before but i want
clarification on page two there's bolded
language that starts on page i'm sorry
on line 22
or on 21
um
and it it basically uh refers to
let's see
to the extent the department acts
pursuant to an existing rule order or
approval the department shall not be
subject to rsa 541
a29 or rsa 541 a29a
and i just want to understand i think we
did cover that before but if you could
just explain to us what they're being
exempted from
when they're acting on a rule
so um
rsa 541a29
establishes timelines by which an agency
has to act on a petition request or
application
and those timelines are 30 days to
identify items that are missing from an
application
to identify who's going to be working on
it etc
um
and then 60 days to
act
on on that application right
or to open an adjudicative proceeding
okay
so
the
then rsa 541 8
29a
says that if you fail to meet those
deadlines then the application is
automatically granted it's deemed
granted sort of as a matter of law i
remember this now it's coming back to me
yeah so
it's those provisions that the
department would be exempted from
thank you
okay additional discussion or any
questions for mr shulock while he is at
the table representative callie pitts
would a blanket
exemption
in other words instead of having to go
and ask for an exemption or have an
exemption granted or have it publicly
granted
would a blanket exemption just you can
do as you wish
well time wise
there are limits um there are limits in
rules
that that would be applied to many of
these things
um and then
some of them just take time i mean they
are resolved in in due course but
things like customer complaints
can are difficult to resolve in a 30-day
period because the result require
negotiations
you know between the utility and and the
um the customer
follow-up uh was b what takes precedence
what's in statute
which would we are doing
or the rules
the statute and the rules um
do not conflict if this
exemption is is placed in the statute
okay additional questions for mr shulock
or discussion of the
question of adopting
this amendment
one more question from representative
mcgee thank you
um and this question is
at the top of page two there's some
language that's removed starting on line
three
but the sentence uh that it that that
sentence that the section of the
sentence that's removed modifies is
section seven
ensure that the department provides all
necessary support to the public
utilities commission the site evaluation
committee office of the consumer
advocate and any other entity that is
administratively attached to the
department and then after the comment is
removed and it says provided that
other than for administrative functions
department employees shall not
communicate with the public utilities
commission and its staff in connection
with any issue in a matter pending
before the commission or the department
except upon notice and opportunity for
all parties to participate and i
understand how that might be
tricky to administer but i also think
that
that that language is very specific to
the red line that we've discussed
between the two
agencies
so that that is what was referred to as
the bright red line the problem was that
it in
practice it was quite fuzzy
um and prohibited
or seemed to prohibit
made difficult conversations between the
two agencies
that made it difficult to achieve the
efficiencies that i think that the
statute was aimed at
so
the
what we proposed was to sharpen that
bright red line a little bit
by taking out the language that you see
there on page two
and substituting language that appears
on page one
at lines 19 and 20.
we which says that in adjudicative
proceedings as defined
by the administrative procedures act the
public utilities commission and
department shall be subject to
a provision of the
administrative procedures act that deals
with ex parte communications and that
prohibits communications between
decision makers and advisors and anyone
uh on the outside
so it would
would prohibit department employees from
having substantive discussions about
ongoing adjudicative
the substance of ongoing adjudicative
matters
at the commission with the puc right and
vice versa because the department will
also have adjudicative proceedings
thank you to follow up on representative
mcgee's question
the
provisions of rsa 541a colon
36.
spell out what the bright red line looks
like
yes it prohibits ex partake uh
conversations yeah
great thank you
further discussion representative oxenam
looking for clarification here thank you
mr chair
um
how is it possible for the department to
have adjudicative proceedings
we manage other programs federal
programs
um and occasionally complaints may be
filed and those would need to be
adjudicated
and that the public utilities commission
has no jurisdiction over those
so they would be adjudicated in-house as
they were adjudicated at osi
i did not know that osi had that thank
you
thank you further discussion or
questions
seeing none i thank you mr shulock for
being here to help us with uh this
amendment
and you can stay a few more minutes just
in case uh we'd appreciate that and feel
free to take a cookie
and we'd like to thank all of you for
taking the time with this amendment and
helping us thank you
and as representative mcgee indicated
help yourself to cookies or cupcakes or
whatever
all right uh representative platt has a
question yes mr chair after we go
through the roll call for the amendment
and then the roll call for the bill
could we take a one minute break so we
can get cookies
right now no after the roll call after
the roll call okay yes we'll take a one
minute cookie break after the roll call
all right seeing no further discussion
i'm going to ask the clerk to call the
role on the question of the adoption of
the amendment 2022-050851h
to house bill 1258 mr clerk yes mr chair
aye
representative thomas
yes representative harrington yes
representative notter yes representative
berner yes representative plett votes
yes representative berezini yes
representative bernardi yes
representative campbell's yes
representative pleasure yes
representative white yes representative
lewicki yes representative messemia yes
massa miller yes okay fixed uh
representative massimilia said yes
a representative uh
okay kelly pitts
represent kelly pitts
yes or no
okay
representative mann
uh not voting
you have to vote okay i will vote gnome
representative accident
no
replica of horrigan
representative mcgee
yes representative mcwilliams
grudgingly yes
representative hacken phillips did i
pronounce it correctly yes and yes you
did
representative pimentel yes
representative partial yes and the chair
yes okay
uh that would make it uh
18 4.
thank you by a vote of 18 to 4 amendment
is adopted
representative harrington is recognized
for a motion mr chairman i ask that we
uh
vote ought to pass as amended on hb
representative notter is recognized i
second the motion it's been moved and
seconded that we adopt hb
1258 as amended by
2022-0851 h
is there further discussion
seeing none i ask the clerk to call the
roll after which we will take a cookie
break
most
important representative thomas
yes representative harrington
yes professor ignata yes representative
berner yes representative pled votes yes
representative berezni yes professor
bernardi yes representative campbell's
yes representative pleasure yes
representative white yes
representative lewicki yes
representative massa miller yes
professor kelly pitts
representative mann yes purpose
yes
representative horrigan yes
representative mcgee
yes representative mcwilliams
yes representative
hackett phillips yes
representative pimentel yes
and representative partial yes and the
chair
yes 22 nothing
by a vote of 22 the nothing the
bill hb 1258 is adopted as amended
i suspect this bill is
not the kind of bill that we want to put
on the consent calendar because if
someone looks in the calendar and sees
this amendment
being what 10 11 pages long they may
have questions so we will not put this
bill on the consent calendar even though
it passes with a unanimous bipartisan
vote
and with that we will take a
eight minute cookie break please be back
in your seats at 10 35 thank you
thank you
i have to officially close the exact
session on 12 58. done the length of the
amendment means it can't
never happen but i would have objected
to consent
it deserves debate if somebody wants a
debate
which they can anyway just we always
have these
arguments on the floor why is this one
here if it was
i know i'm looking at 22.00
one minute
okay it's 10 35 so let's get back to
work now that we've had our
caloric needs satisfied i trust
so i would like to now open the public
hearing
on house bill 1491-fn-local
relative to natural gas transmission
pipeline safety
and the chair recognizes representative
murder
yes mr chairman i move out to pass on
1491.
representative loewicky is recognized mr
chairman i second
it has been moved and seconded that we
judge hb 1491 as ought to pass and
representative merner is recognized to
speak to that motion
yes thank you um
mr chairman basically the the bill
requires local and land use boards
uh to notify the operator of the trans
national gas transmission pipeline prior
to approving any project within a
thousand feet of the pipeline
thank you so this bill is basically a
safety measure
and it prevents someone from buying a
piece of property next to a
existing pipeline and there's only one
in new hampshire and that's up in the
northern part of the state
prevents someone from buying a piece of
property and then putting in a swimming
pool too close to a to the pipeline
that's the purpose of this bill it's
fairly simple and straightforward
representative pementel
thank you mr chairman uh we did get an
amendment on this bill are we going to
do the amendment
uh
0547h
i had forgotten that thank you for
mentioning that
the next question will be how many of us
actually have a copy of that amendment
yeah right representative pimentel can
you refresh our memory as to the purpose
and the subject of the amendment
um
yeah the amendment uh
is inserting by section two of the bill
by replacing it with the following
for a new residential or non-residential
development that is located in whole or
in part within one thousand feet of the
center point of the
of a gas transmission pipeline that was
constructed or operated prior to the
development the applicant shall notify
the operator of the natural gas pipeline
transmission pipeline of the planned
development no later than the time of
application for approval of the
development
or 180 days
to commencement of construction
whichever is earlier
and then there is
amend rsa
colon 75
section 4
as inserting
by section 2 of this of the bill by
replacing it with the following so this
would be a new section 4.
within 60 days of the effective date of
this section a local land use board
in a
municipality
that is within one thousand feet of the
center point of the natural gas
transmission pipeline shall make
national pipeline mapping system
geospatial
data available
to developers from the pipeline and
hazardous materials safety
administration within the united states
department of transportation
relative to the locations of the
pipeline
thank you representative pementel as i
recall that last section
was designed to prevent
imposing on local municipalities a
requirement that they
invest in
some fairly expensive maps
whether there's a pipeline anywhere near
their town or not which was a a good
amendment
so i think we're going to want to adopt
this amendment
and in order for us to do that i think
we're going to have to have copies made
so that everybody can see this amendment
so
kristin we're making you a busy lady
today because we're going to ask you to
make a copy of this amendment
and
return to us as quickly as possible
with that
amendment and then we will ask a uh for
someone to make a motion to adopt the
amendment
is there is there a question
representative murner
oh okay
so is there any general discussion
before we get the copies back from
kristen representative mick williams has
it
uh thank you chevos
i have a logistics question here um
for the amended section two where the
applicant shall notify the operator of
the natural gras gas transmission
pipeline how exactly does that work how
does the applicant notify the natural
gas transmissions pipeline
a good question
the natural gas pipeline transmission
company would be or pipeline owner would
be a company like tc energy in the case
of the only pipeline that runs through
new hampshire
and
i'm sure that their offices
are reachable through
normal channels i'm sure the
planning board or
other municipal
office with within the town would have
the address of tc energy so
one would assume that that's how the
notification would happen
follow-up follow-up
and then what is the enforcement if they
fail to do so
fail to notify within the timeline 180
days so six months you've got a
developer who buys a parcel they're
gonna put a house sorry developer buys a
parcel they're gonna put a house on it
they have
a six-month
deadline here to let tc energy know hey
i'm going to put a house up on this
parcel and they fail to do it so what
happens if they fail
there's a chair
representative thomas um i think during
public hearing i
i'm i believe i asked that question to
the individual at the time
and
basically the response and it may have
been offline too so i apologize but i
think the answer was
that if they don't notify
that's fine but when they find out
they have the power to
delay the actual construction or say you
you can't put it here or in other ways
to say that
you you didn't notify us therefore
you're within the thousand foot foot
mark and we are putting a stop to your
construction so that's one of the
repercussions of not notifying
them at all now how they do it i i don't
know
representative plett
yes i will point out on page two of the
bill
line seven a building permit shall not
be issued and the building shall not be
erected in a lot within the jurisdiction
of a local land use board unless one of
the following threat free criteria and
met are met the developer receive
written consent developers not receive
written consent
but has filed with such local and used
board written correspondence uh
demonstrating discussions and outreach
have occurred or the developers filed
and dated a written correspondent with
such local unions for the land use board
that demonstrates attempts to contact so
it's covered they can't build and get a
building permit without those conditions
well represent
representative murder yeah i was trying
to get in earlier
with the mapping system that's going to
be provided to all land use boards up
there with this pipeline
when they apply for the application
they're going to have to notify the land
use board will notify
the abutters because they have to about
them anyways to approve the project and
with that thousand foot offset it would
automatically kick in
okay
representative mick williams does that
answer your questions
yes it does thank you thank you great
thank you representative callie
pitts did you have a question yeah i
just like a clarification
there's only one pipeline in new
hampshire now
we don't distinguish what consists of a
pipeline
i remember when the gas plant was built
in derry
there was a big
question
about putting
a quote-unquote
pipeline which probably is not a
pipeline is a distribution line or
whatever
up to that plant near a school so what
is the classification
or the definition of pipeline does it
have to have so much capacity does it
have to have
what does a pipeline have to have
representative thomas can answer that
question uh thank you mr chair and again
i believe
i asked that question at time of the
public hearing again maybe offline i'm
not sure
i think the distinction is that the
pipeline that we're talking about in
this bill
is the only transmission pipeline
in the state the other pipelines are
distribution
and the differentiation is that this is
a transmission pipeline governed by ferc
and i i believe that is the
the actual distinction that's why it
applies only this pipeline up up north
representative platt mr chair i would
ask the mover and second until we'd
rather motion in second and make another
new motion and second directed towards
the amendment rather than the bill
representative murderer would you
withdraw your original motion and make
an emotion to
adopt the amendment please yes withdraw
and that and would you move to amend
the bill with
2022-05478 yes i make a motion to amend
with uh 20-22-0547-h
representative wiki i second so it's
moved in seconded that we adopt
amendment
2022-05 47h
is there any discus further discussion
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the role on the adoption of amendment
2022-0547
h to house bill 1491
representative thomas
yes representative harrington yes
representative notter yes representative
mirner yes representative platfos yes
representative berezni yes
representative bernardi yes represent
cambrils yes representative pleasure yes
representative white yes representative
wiki yes
representative massimilia massimilla
sorry it's okay
i'll get it
okay in in spanish it would be masamiya
yeah
uh
okay uh cali pit represent kelly pitts
representative mann yes representative
oxenoum yes representative horrigan yes
representative mcgee yes represent mc
williams yes representative hackett
phillips yes representative pimentel
yes representative partial yes
and the chair
yes
22 nothing
by a vote of 22 to nothing the amendment
2022-05 47 h is adopted
representative murder is recognized for
a motion
mr chairman i move that we move
house bill 1491 as amended
a lot to pass representative lewicki i
second
it's been moved and seconded that we
adopt
house bill 1491 as
amended by amendment 20 22 05 47 h any
further discussion on this bill
representative mcgee thank you mr
chairman i only had one note here from
our discussion on the bill and i
probably should have brought it up with
the amendment but
um on page two
section six it says a building permit
shall not be issued
and in our discussion we discussed
changing it to may
not be issued from shell and i don't
it's a knit but
that was what we discussed at the time
and um i don't know if it makes a big
difference but it seems like it might
the senate can change representative
oxendine do you have a comment
thank you for calling on me mr chair yes
i certainly recall i've been looking
at the amendment where's the may where's
the may because i remember we had quite
a lengthy discussion
at which we agreed uh on on the may and
it was
i think that may be why most of you
didn't have the amendment because we
were told we'd get a new one that would
have the may
in it
uh representative liewicki
thank you mr chairman um as written this
would effectively be a taking in my mind
is this not correct
representative platt
actually i and
shall i kind of like
uh is it because you do not get a permit
unless you notify or you are those other
conditions
that's that's harsh
so um just to be clear about the
difference between shall and may
keeping shall in means that we are
giving the power to the existing
pipeline
to issue or not issue a permit based on
communications with that pipeline shall
means the pipeline is basically doing a
taking of an existing property that
someone would like to develop
the may leaves the authority with the
existing authority having jurisdiction
which is often the municipal office of
building
often or whoever the town uses to
outsource that so in effect you would
actually be moving the authority from
your local building jurisdiction to the
pipeline about whether or not you can
build there and frankly i don't think
that's what we intended to do
representative platt mr chair i would
suggest an amendment be made
with ols quickly and we recess this till
it's back
all right
let's have a show of hands how many
people think we should recess this
executive session and obtain
a new amendment that uses the word may
instead of shall
please so indicate by raising your hand
okay we will recess this public hearing
and obtain a
i mean this uh executive session rather
and obtain a new amendment very
important that includes the word
may instead of shall
so kristen
the biggest busiest lady in the room
today
so the public hearing on
the
executive session on house bill 1491 is
recessed
and if you'll bear with me for a moment
i just need to give kristen some
instructions
so she can uh
well she has her own copy so
does she see where the maid belongs it's
very important where the may goes
rebecca yeah
all right so to clarify the situation
when we resume this executive session
the first order of business will be to
reconsider
the vote on the amendment that we
adopted
and we will all vote no
vote yes on reconsideration
and then we'll we will vote no on the
amendment
to
get rid of the first amendment
then we'll have a motion on a second
amendment which we'll have back from ols
by then
and kristen the the time frame on that
is asap
okay great thank you
representative you have a comment yes uh
mr chairman i have a question
since we are amending a different
portion of the bill
can we
we would i would think we would either
have to include the previous amendment
with the um in this new amendment um in
order to make it correct
yes the new amendment will contain the
two paragraphs of the old amendment plus
a new paragraph that changes the word
shell to may
okay
representative pimentel
thank you mr chairman
isn't the last amendment we
pass the amendment that
is used
therefore we don't really have to
uh un undo the other amendment
the new amendment would just
that is not correct because you can only
report a bill out of committee with one
amendment
so we have to combine the two amendments
and so it wouldn't make the first
amendment moot then no okay thank you
that's why we have to reconsider it once
we
reconvene the executive session
all right so
given the fact that we have to move on
i think we will deal next since we're
coming up on the lunch hour
we will deal next with house bill 1611.
so i'm going to open an executive
session on house bill 1611
and i'm going to recognize
representative harrington thank you mr
speaker i moved to uh
itl uh hb 1611.
representative bernardi is recognized
i second that motion it's been moved and
seconded
that we judge house bill 1611 to be
itl
is there any discussion
representative
occidum
could i request an explanation of why
representative harrington is yeah
there's actually a couple of reasons
first there's no compelling need for the
bill uh in the near future because there
are no projects that would be affected
by these changes that's in the
site evaluation committee queue
that's kind of slowed down quite a bit
and again this these changes would not
affect wind projects for example
second thing is there's been some
discussion between the house and the
senate on a bigger picture review of the
site evaluation committee and it would
be make more sense to roll whatever of
this bill we thought was a good idea
into those discussions and address that
at a later time in a more comprehensive
uh bill
further discussion on the motion to itl
house bill 1611
representative mann did you want to make
a no okay
well seeing none i guess i'm going to
ask the clerk to call the role on the
motion of itl on house bill 1611 mr
clerk
we're still preparing on the last bill
that needs to be done so i'm just
getting to 16 11. um
okay uh and uh
okay it was
am i correct that the motion was by
harrington and second by barish
bernardi okay
okay
um
itl okay
while he's doing this upset this work i
just want to commend
representative plett for being an
outstanding committee clerk he's done a
great job all year long
[Applause]
what he's trying to tell me is go out
stan stand outside
so you're now you now have the floor to
call the
on the motion of itl on hb 1611. thank
you representative thomas yes
representative harrington yes
representative notter yes representative
murder yes representative plett
the votes yes representative
yes represent bernardi yes president
campbells yes representative please yes
representative white yes representative
lewicki yes
representative massimila yes
but i misspelled your name the first
time so i'm fixing it as i go along
um
representative cali pitts
representative mann yes representative
oxford
yes representative horrigan yes
representative mcgee yes representative
mcwilliams
yes representative hacken phillips yes
representative pimentel yes
uh representative partial yes
and the chair yes 21-0
21-1 sorry yes it was a mis
speak the 21-1. by a vote of 21 to 1
house bill 1611 is judged to be itl
and without objection we'll put it on
the consent calendar
okay there is an objection so it will
not be put on the consent calendar
all right
so
kristen can you give us an update on the
uh amendment to house bill 1546
okay thank you
representative callie pitts do you
intend to write a minority report
okay fine
just asking to find out for the record
if there would be a minority report
that's all
okay i'm going to take a um
i'm going to take a 10 minute bio break
in the hopes that we get the amendment
to hb5 1546 in the next few minutes
so i'd ask everyone to return to your
seats by 10 past 11. thank you
representative oxendine do you have a
question yes could you tell us which
bill will be
just so we could be prepared when we
come back to start right up what which
bill will be taking up
okay so it is my intent provided that we
get the
uh amendment on hb 1546 to take that up
at 10 minutes past 11.
thank you
okay 10 minute recess
okay everybody let's get started again
let's resume
the executive session
on uh house bill
14 a 1546 fn
so we have an amendment being drafted
it may even be ready
so it is it is ready but and could you
please pass that out kristen
but before we reconsider the previous
amendment
and adopt this new amendment there is
some further discussion i think that we
need to have and
that further discussion relates to the
fact
that
well i'm gonna let representative thomas
tell you uh explain it because
he explained it to me but i got it third
hand he got it first hand so he can
explain it better than i can
thank you mr chair i i did have a just
now a conversation with the
the person that represents the
transmission pipeline
um
they're okay with either way we go on
may or shall
but the bottom line is this
if you
uh
if if you put main there and the t and
giving the town the authority to whether
or not they can overrule what the
transmission pipeline says
uh their uh prerogative
if
the result is that you wind up do
building something closer than the
thousand foot
then that would change the
classification of the pipeline or the
project going to the pipeline at that
point the federal agency fisma which is
sort of like the equivalent of ferc
would get involved they're part of the
department of transportation would get
involved and they would basically say
you've just changed the classification
of this project therefore cease and
desist
we're not going to allow you to build
there
and so the
the bottom line is that if you if you
however you decided if you build within
that thousand foot you're changing the
classification of that project and
you'll get fisma come down and and
basically say uh you've
by our rules by federal rules you can't
build that that project there so either
way it would be it would behoove the
town planners to just accept the
transmissions um you know
authorization
to uh whether or not they could you know
build or not
so either way uh shall or may um
it the end result is uh if you do then
you might get fism down to to let you
know what you could or couldn't do and
that's that's about how it was explained
to me it very rarely happens that way
but you know it could
so based on that explanation it would
seem that
to simplify the process here we don't
need to reconsider the previous
amendment and adopt this new amendment
because this new amendment
would have no effect in us in essence
so at this point we should just move
forward with the amendment we already
adopted
representative oxendine do you have uh a
comment
thank you mr chair yes i'm i'm surprised
that when we had this discussion about
may and we had the pipeline
representative in the room
that this matter was not brought up
uh
and i i don't think that we should be
voting on bills on
uh hearsay evidence from a call that one
member had with somebody offline i i
don't i don't think that's a responsible
way for us to go forward well with all
due respect i do remember that that
discussion was had during the public
hearing you did explain that
i don't think it was in regard to the
to a discussion about shall versus may
but it was with regard to how the whole
process works i do remember him talking
about
the
federal versus state jurisdiction in
these matters and it was explained by
him during the course of his testimony
in the public hearing follow-up follow
up
believe me i take extensive notes on
these hearings and i would have taken
cease and desist down and had it
asterisked
that that did not come up
and the the other point
oh
drat um went right out of my head
i'm i i i'm yes that's what it was
if there is a difference between the
feds
moving in and
taking and us as a committee
saying that we are going to authorize
the state
to make a taking
which um i believe was representative
wiki's point
maybe i didn't understand it
use the microphone please representative
yes the question my question was is this
a taking
and
if it is then who provides compensation
rep representative platt it is not a
taking and it's because of the language
in the bill there's no way that this can
be
this gives
the pipeline veto power no way
because
uh
in the bill as i read it
on page two
a building permit shall not be issued
that's true and a building shall not be
erected a lot within the jurisdiction or
local land use board unless one of the
following three criteria are met
the first one is the developers receive
written consent from the natural gas
pipeline operator has filed such consent
but if they don't get consent there's
two other conditions and the the
developers not receive written consent
but has filed with such locally and
land use board written correspondence
from the pipeline are operated
discussing that
demonstrating the discussions and
outreach have occurred and the third one
is the developers file dated and written
correspondence with such locally unused
belinda's board that demonstrates
attempts to contact the natural gas
pipeline operator and that no response
has been received within 180 days of the
filing so if a developer goes and tries
to reach out to the pipeline opera they
don't get a response within 180 days
they're out of the picture so there's no
way that there's a veto power by the
pipeline
representative thomas
thank you mr chair and i i might note
that in in my notes um
again the uh
the
person representing tc energy said that
quote
this bill doesn't allow gas company to
deny permit only to have a conversation
so that was the intent of this entire
bill
okay
any further discussion representative
mcwilliams
thank you representative thomas for
clarifying the intent from the pipeline
company
um i i'm feeling like the language in
section six is rather draconian if that
truly is the pipe pipeline's intent was
just to get notification so this whole
first line of written consent
sounds rather draconian if that's not
their intention all along why does it
say written consent
so
that part i don't think should even be
in there if that's not the intention of
the pipeline
the attempt to contact i get i get that
um i i get that you might send something
return receipt requested to tci and say
you know i need to get this postcard
back so that i can move forward with my
building permit application but it's
creating an additional step for the the
local municipality to track
okay we've got this developer who's
doing their checklist to do a permit for
a new building on a lot that they've
purchased and add in one more line have
they reached out to the pipeline because
this property according to the maps and
that's i think that's the key thing that
this bill does is it forces the
municipalities to put the maps online
which makes it super easy for anyone
who's buying a lot to see okay what are
the local jurisdiction requirements i'm
looking at the local building code and
there are these maps that are applicable
and it says if you're in this zone you
need to notify the pipeline that's
really how it works so the crux of this
is not really about written consent and
i i take offense to adding that
additional what i see as an honoris step
for a developer to have to get written
consent which is why i'm saying let's
stick with the may
rather than shall let's not be draconian
let's not be forcing this let's simply
make it very obvious that this is
something you need to do
it is something that is being added to
the checklist
but it is not a
stop everything right now it is more of
a this is how the process will now work
and and i really don't think that we
want to have municipalities who are
saying you can't possibly have a
building permit because we're being told
by the state that we can't issue a
building permit because there's this
pipeline so you can't have a building
permit i don't think that that's the way
we want this to function it really seems
to me like we're adding additional
layers here when the reality is we're
just smoothing the process out we're
providing maps we're making it very
obvious that this is the checklist so
it's about the language and it's also
this whole written consent thing just
really turns me off so shall vs may to
me is a big point
mr
thomas uh thank you mr chair yes i um
on this particular issue on this bill i
don't have a hard issue with shell or
may
um i think in this particular normally i
do have an issue with shallows versus
maize but in this case whether it's a
shallower or may
if the town doesn't follow the
recommendation i think they're going to
get hit over the knuckles anyway so
i'm perfectly willing to go with may um
if if that
is comforting to
everybody here because i think that
there's enough
federal uh involvement that could
could absolutely protect the safety
which is what we're primarily trying to
do here
right i have an operational issue here
did
anybody receive a copy of an amendment
for this bill
okay i received two copies of an
amendment but they're both for the same
bill which is not this bill
yeah yeah so we don't have an amendment
yet so
representative lewicki you have a
comment
thank you mr chairman yes i do um
all of the property within uh that
contains the transmission line at this
point has an easement that says such and
such number of feet from the center line
of the pipeline i would assume that this
is less than a thousand feet if we pass
this bill we have effectively increased
the size of that easement it becomes a
loose easement over that thousand feet
but it's still an easement which was not
in the pre-existing contract with the
landowners
and i also made the point in
representative mcgee's right now i also
made the point in the hearing that that
thousand feet from the center line goes
from the center line both ways so it's
actually 2 000 feet so it's an awful lot
of land that we're talking about that's
affected
but
i don't think we have any solution for
that but that's it's a lot of land
correct
all right well since we represented
harrington is recognized
you know i've been listening to this
discussion there's a lot going on with
going back and forth and i guess i step
back for a little bit and say
why is it so important that we get this
passed down we have one pipeline in the
state there's no known problems maybe
it's an issue in other parts of the
country where this pipeline is literally
running all over the place i don't know
if sounds to me with all this back and
forth about whether it's a legitimate uh
issue just raised about a taking you're
certainly extending the size of the
easement substantially uh the may versus
shall i think if it has a may it has no
teeth because then the applicant just
doesn't have to do anything so i this
would be right for interim study as far
as i can see we're passing something
here we don't really know what we're
passing on what the effect is going to
be so that would be my recommendation
representative murder
yeah i represent this whole pipeline i
represent 12 towns in cohorts county and
it's built on unbuildable land 90 of the
land that we're talking about the 2000
feet if you want to
go you know on either side of it and
it's not a problem i mean
i mean
i think putting this in statute and i
think the most important part on this
amendment which i can hand to you if you
haven't seen it is section 4 of
requiring the mapping which you two have
the most questions on that answers all
of it uh
you know
what's going going forward so
we can debate this all day it's you know
because like i say i represent that
whole area and
that's the amendment that we're talking
about everyone says they don't have
no we have one that's out to ols right
now
that's
pointless it's totally pointless
okay
thank you
representative callie pitts you have a
question i have a
real question
if
if you buy a piece of land
and there is a pipeline say 50 years
from now people are unaware that there's
a pipeline running under there is there
something on the deed that says that
this is so
so if i buy a tractor land and
it i
is there something on the deed to that
land that says
that there is a pipeline under that land
not above it but under it
is there any anything that indicates
that
yes
if you buy a piece of land
and then you decide you want to put a
house on it
develop it
the first thing the local planning board
do will be to notify all abutters of
your intention
if the pipeline owns property that abuts
your property they will receive a notice
that you intend to
build on that property
and they can take action to discover
whether or not
your proposed development will impact
the pipeline
so
yes
there will be
if you buy a piece of land there will be
information available to you about the
existence of the pipeline and its
location yeah
may i i i just want to get it clear so i
buy a piece of land which i never will
do
and i'm gonna there's there's a pipeline
underneath it running underneath it
buried pipeline
on the deed
before i buy that land
is there something that indicates that
there is a pipeline that runs
under that property so that i'm aware
of what's there and what's not that
you know i that that's all i wanted to
know because we have
had instances where there have been
lines sewer lines on properties
that nobody knew about
so i i just wanted to know does that
happen
no that's not the case with a
transmission pipeline no you cannot buy
land that is over a transmission
pipeline it's not for sale
representative murder well it's like
it's like railways uh existing power
lines big everything has right-of-way
this is where this is a transmission
line it is a right-of-way so it cannot
be done so that's the word you're
looking for
yeah
representative wiki thank you mr
chairman any existing pipeline or
electrical transmission line has
easements across properties those
easements are on the deed and they are
registered with the registry of deeds so
if you were to buy such a property it
would be in the deed and it would be
known it's not some it is well known and
well registered
representative platt
yes i
don't know whether the
actual easement or ownership by the
pipeline is a thousand feet each side
it's probably a lot shorter than that
but and they cannot veto anything
outside of their out of the outside of
their easement or ownership but all
they're looking for is advise and
consent can you do it this way rather
than that way that's all
representative oxen did you have another
comment
i think it was answered thank you
okay
representative thomas thank you mr chair
i just want to go over again that this
is a
bill that is strictly to strengthen
communications between the transmission
company and the towns
doesn't change any rules doesn't change
any existing rules but they want
language in there to really strengthen
the point that you must have a
communication with us
because
it might be a case where they might say
it's okay
uh within so many feet and there may be
cases where they say
you shouldn't because of classification
changes so the
overall intent of this bill was just to
provide stronger safety measures and
stronger communication
and that's all that that's all the uh
the originator was intended uh with this
bill
so i'm not sure how more i can say that
but that's all it is it's not changing
any existing regulations rules it's only
strengthening communications dialogue
okay i'd like to get a sense of the
committee on this bill
we uh have an amendment that we could
adopt it's not back from ols yet but we
could adopt it later today or
we could do something
entirely different
so i'm going to suggest that we take a
lunch break now since it's almost 11 30
and
return at one o'clock
or return it 12 45
and resume
this
executive session
by that time we'll have the amendment
from ols
and we can decide how we want to proceed
so
for now let's take a brief
hour and 15 minute recess for lunch and
let's reassemble at 12 45
to decide what to do on this bill thanks
i mean this is ridiculous we have a two
hour we have a two o'clock public
hearing correct yes
so we won't be able to finish the rest
okay one hour for lunch see you at
twelve
thirty things at the same
this is a one-hour time
is a one-hour what caucus what is this
what does this say
what does dick say
they let you know
but they know where things are they know
they there
okay everyone 12 31 time to get back to
work
hope everybody had a good lunch
and
i would like to now
resume
the
executive session on house bill 1491
f in local
and i'm going to hope
that kristen will soon supply us
with copies
of
amendment 2022-0903-h
what this amendment does
is it
codifies
the amendment we previously adopted
and then adds
amended language to section 4 that
changes the word shall
to may
in two different locations
and then it also
changes the language to indicate that
only one of the three
subsequent conditions needs to be met
not all of them as the previous language
indicated
so as soon as we get that
language we'll be able to move forward
in the meantime what we
have to do is we have to reconsider our
vote
on amendment
2022-0547-h
we voted to adopt that amendment
representative thomas thank you mr um
could you
review what you just said there i'm a
little bit confused i thought the
amendment
that we were waiting for
was just a word change from child to may
well we'll find out in a couple of
seconds because
the copies of the amendment just arrived
so thank you kristen for arranging for
that
yes thank you so they did
they took out the knot so
maybe issued
and then he changed it to
so long as one of the problems right
okay
so
in addition to the word shall being
changed to may in two places
on line 20
the words
so long as one of the following criteria
met
was substituted for the original
language of the bill
so i needed i need someone who voted on
the prevailing side to move
reconsideration of amendment 0547h
representative bernardi is recognized
thank you mr chairman i move that we
reconsider
is there a second
representative berezni
whole second
it's been moved and seconded that we
reconsider
amendment
o5447h i urge
everyone to vote no
and i ask the clerk to
call the roll on the motion to
reconsider
yes to reconsider i'm sorry yes to
on the motion of 0547h
okay the clerk will call the roll please
come to order
motion was made by j.d bernardi and
seconded by representative berezini
all right
this is a reconsideration so the
reconsideration of
uh 2202 20220547h
if you're in favor you will want to
reconsider if you're opposed you don't
want to reconsider representative thomas
yes
representative harrington yes president
of notter
reluctantly yes
representative murder yes representative
platt
yes representative berezni yes
representative bernardi yes
representative campbell's yes
representative pleasure yes
representative white yes representative
lewicki yes representative massa miller
yes represent kelly pitts
representative mann
representative oxford
representative horrigan yes
representative mcgee yes representative
williams yes
representative hacken phillips yes
representative
pimentel representative partial
and the chair yes okay 22-0 to
reconsider okay now we can reconsider
this amendment
so
the motion on the floor
was to pass
amendment zero five four seven h to
adopt that amendment
i would like to now recall that question
and ask everyone to vote no
we're just second here i gotta catch up
with this i gotta save you to these
folks
why do we want to vote no on
adopting this amendment
because we want to unadopt it
essentially so that we can adopt a new
amendment
so
that's why i'm asking you to vote no on
the motion to adopt this amendment okay
okay
i'll call this re-adopter to keep them
separate okay
so as the clerk indicated a moment ago
the motion on the floor is to adopt the
amendment zero five four seven h
if you vote yes you will vote to adopt
it if you vote no you will vote not to
adopt it
i urge you to vote no
mr clerk i'm using the same form so i
have to delete all the x's so give me
one more second
after we finish this bill we're going to
move on to
hb
1546 fn and we have an amendment for
that bill as well
you ready mr clerk i will be in a second
okay the motion
is to re-adopt
uh
amendment zero five four seven h
and if you vote yes you wanna re-adopt
it if you vote no you want it dead
uh all those are so all the favor uh
representative thomas
reluctantly yes
you you want to re-adopt it oh no
okay
uh representative harrington no
representative daughter reluctantly no
representative berner no
representative platford's votes no
representative berezni no representative
bernardi no representative campbell's no
representative pleasure no
representative white no representative
lewicki no rapper masamila yes that's
miller sorry representative callie pitts
representative band no representative
no
representative horrigan no
representative mcgee no
represent mc williams no representative
hacken phillips no representative
pimentel
uh representative partial
and the chair no okay by a zero to 22
vote
it is killed
okay by a vote of zero to 22 amendment
0547h
is unadopted
for lack of a better term i now
recognize representative murder for a
motion
thank you thank you mr chairman i i
moved to adopt um
20 2209
[Music]
03 h
members
representative notter is recognized a
second
it's been moved and seconded that we
adopt
amendment 2022 0903 h for hb
1491. fn local is there any discussion
yes mr chair
representative thomas
yes i'm a little bit confused
i thought that we were
going to just change the word child to
may
and in the original bill
that would have read a building permit
may not be issued but yet as i'm seeing
here
the word not has been omitted so i'd
like to have an explanation
as to why the words not
was omitted when we intent wishes to
change from shall to may
well i can answer that that was a typo
the drafting attorney made that error
because we did not ask him to change
make that change
and so he must have
made that error on his own
okay one at a time please representative
not or do you have a question
so are you saying that this new
amendment is still not right
apparently not mr chair
representative platt i think it's fine
it says a building permit may be issued
uh so long as one of the following three
criteria are met
otherwise it's not issued and so it's
it's so it it did not it has no effect
oh you're right you're right it is
correct you're right
representative thomas do you see that
now it is correct it says a building
permit may be issued and a building may
be erected
provided that one of the following
criteria is met
i was just looking for an explanation
okay
all right so phew
you had me worried there for a minute it
looks like we we got this okay okay any
further discussion on this amendment
does this satisfy everyone's objections
to the original
language
seeing none
i'll ask the clerk to call the role on
the adoption of amendment 2022-0903-h
to hb
1491 fn mr clerk okay and what i'm going
to do is find out
i think there'll be no changes so i can
just mark it up is where i saved
the uh original adoption
of 40547h
and i'm going to change that to
0.903h
it's a tough job being clerk but we got
a good man on the on the case i don't
know about that
okay i've got uh the roll call set up
for 0.903h
this okay this is committee will be in
order this is to adopt oh
adopt
come on adopt
okay it's to adopt if i spell it
correctly
20220903h
uh representative thomas
yes
i heard you i got to get to that part of
the screen
there representative thomas yes
representative harrington yes professor
nader yes representative mirner yes
representative
votes yes representative berezini yes
representative bernardi yes represent
cambrils yes representative pelosi yes
representative white yes representative
lewicki yes representative massa miller
yes governor kelly pitts
representative kelly pitts
but i didn't hear your vote
uh representative mann
representative oxford
yes representative horrigan yes
representative mcgee yes representative
mc williams yes representative hacken
phillips yes representative pimentel yes
representative partial yes and the chair
yes it's 21-1
by a vote of 21-1 the amendment 0903-h
is adopted
we now are on to the question of the
adoption of
hp 1491 as amended is there any
discussion on that motion
seeing none i asked the clerk to call
the roll
uh representative thomas has a question
uh point of order uh we had uh the
original motion was withdrawn so a new
motion has to be made at this
point okay thank you for that reminder
representative merner can you make a
motion for us please
yes
i i move that we take
hp 1491 otp as amended
representative nader is recognized i
second the motion it's been moved and
seconded that we adopt
hbn 1491 as amended by
zero nine zero three h okay
is there any further discussion
seeing none ask the clerk to call the
role on the question i have to create a
new uh exec because i ran out of space
on the original exams give me one second
okay while the clerk is doing that i'll
explain that as soon as we complete this
executive session we'll be opening a
executive session on house bill
or we will be reconvening the executive
session on 1546
and we will be looking to adopt
amendment
2022-0899
h
so be prepared for that
okay
i'm just about ready
all right we're going on to let's see 14
okay
uh r2p
change otp to otpa and i'm all set uh
okay
representative thomas
yes
i'm stuck on the header screen hold on
and finally our representative thomas
was a yes representative harrington yes
representative notter yes representative
mirner yes representative platfords yes
representative berezni yes
representative bernardi yes represent
cambrils yes representative pleasure yes
representative white
yes representative lewicki yes represent
massimilia yes
seems to correct your spelling
representative callie pitts
representative mann yes representative
oxford yes representative horrigan yes
representative mcgee yes
representative mcwilliams yes
representative hacken phillips yes
representative
pimentel yes representative partial yes
and the chair yes 22-0 by a vote of 22
to zero
house bill 1491
fn
local
is
judged to be ought to pass as amended
and i thank you all for doing that
any objection to putting in on consent
seeing none it will go on to the consent
calendar and thank you all for that
so that closes the executive session on
hb 1491
and i will now
reopen the executive session
on house bill
fn
and
representative thomas is recognized to
make uh an amendment to make a motion
oh i'm sorry representative notter is
recognized
thank you mr chair i move to adopt
amendment
2022-08998
representative thomas is recognized
second
it's moved and seconded that we adopt
2022-09
h
the amendment to hb 1546 is there any
discussion
representative notter
it's a very short little amendment
it's about the pfas which is a very um
important issue for my town in merrimack
and surrounding towns and there's always
a new
pfas out there and that comes up so this
just defines it
which is good because it's uh pfas is a
crucial topic and then many
are in use commercially and are
quietly being exempted from federal
rulemaking so this amendment also gives
the des tells them to keep studying it
so that
when they do identify
more pfas they can suggest legislation
as needed
okay
uh any further dis
excuse me any further discussion
representative callie pitts
my town is a town that in portsmouth
we're also affected by pfas
and
i
i'm confused by this amendment we are
still
looking at
inhaled pfas
portsmouth is attempting right now
studies on
inhaled pfas and that's going to cost a
quite a bit of money
and it is very difficult to determine
also it is difficult to determine
whether those toxins
are the cause of a health problem
and that's because
there are many and pfas is all around it
my badge my water
my body most of what we have in the air
has some sort of
pfas in it whether we like it or not
it's there
so
i don't understand which studies the des
is going to take
and use are they going to look for a
local study a study that's been done
someplace else and
are they going to report those studies
to anyone it doesn't seem
if the study exists the commissioner may
modify the list of regular ad toxic
but there's different studies say
different things and we had that with
the 5g
different studies say different things
so i i just wonder
what this particular amendment is hoping
to accomplish
thank you
and if i may follow up the studies that
the portsmouth is
attempting to do
are going to cost quite a bit of money
is the
des gonna pay for these studies
is that it that's it okay any further
comment i think uh
the text of the bill representative
harrington go ahead just a question so
just makes this clear we're replacing
everything there's no 45 pound
annual limit it's just now going to be
based on these studies that are spelled
out in the new amendment is that correct
that is correct yes thank you
uh representative oxenom
i i understood everything until the the
last speaker said the studies it what it
says here is if a study exists
if if a study exists i
i don't think i've ever seen a language
like this in a bill
we usually
require a study or we specify a study
but well the language above that on line
nine says that the commissioner shall
conduct a review to determine
whether their ex exists at least one
study that has been accord conducted in
accordance with generally accepted
scientific principles etc etc etc
so
basically what what this bill says is to
the yes go out and find us some studies
on pfas
and
when you find those studies
then you go down to uh line
18 17
it says that once you find the study
that
determines if there's any
developmental health
effects in humans as a result of
inhalation exposure to such pfas
substances
then the commissioner may modify the
list of regulated toxic air pollutants
by adding such pfas analyte to the list
so that's what the bill does
at this point
representative occidum i guess my
follow-up is again we're we're not
specifically calling for a study so
we're not granting funding to an agency
to do a funding but we're saying hey you
know if you find something i'm sorry
it's just it's
well i think i don't see there's any
there there
i think you're nitpicking here i think
this gives clear
uh guidance to the des that they need to
be
finding scientific studies and then
acting upon those studies
representative callie pitts
we have a group a commission that's now
studying pfas and cancer clusters
so how does this
interface with what they're doing
there's no positive proof yet
that i'm aware of and i another a
senator and i'm going to mention his
name dr sherman is
heading that committee and it's been
ongoing since the problem with the
coakley landfill
and the contamination of water
i
and i'm
mac has the same thing with sanco bay
but i'm wondering
how does this
interact with that commission because
i believe that
health and human services and des is
also involved in that commission and
certainly if they came up with a study
that's
concrete which unfortunately or
fortunately nobody has yet
they would be aware of it already
so is this like a piece of feel good
legislation
i guess it potentially could be
you are correct that this
legislation does not mention any study
that's ongoing in portsmouth or any
other community
it specifically
requests that the des commissioner
conduct a review to determine whether
there exists any other studies
at least one of which would be
acceptable for him to
he or she to
change the approved list of of
pfas chemicals i'm just going to follow
up with that what those studies are
is formed by the state of new hampshire
not by the city of portsmouth the city
of portsmouth is doing some independent
stuff on specifically inhalation
but
that's p5 study commission is formed by
the state
so do i understand you to say then that
this bill is not necessary because there
are already state-sponsored studies that
are undergo that are being undertaken
yes sir and very serious studies this is
not an issue to be glanced over
but they are very serious studies that
are going on and going on now
so i guess my question would be then
what harm would passing this legislation
do
representative pimentel
ah thank you mr chairman
basically what this is doing is kind of
maybe eliminate a game of whack-a-mole
uh with pfas and that
um it's allowing the commissioner
to go ahead and
establish or modify
the the classification of these ambient
air for such pfas analyte by adopting
rules in accordance with the provisions
of rsa
541a he's not they're not going to have
to
well
i i think it's uh
it
it's allowing
things to be done without having to go
back to the legislature with
something more specific
other than a study
so
representative mann
thank you mr chairman i my assumption is
that this
says that if as a study gets finished it
automatically will get
the given
uh analyte would be added to the list of
pollutants
so it's kind of an automatic system
you don't have to
do a study and then decide whether it's
going to be added any study
that produces
toxic
the evidence of the toxicity uh would
automatically be added to the list that
are uh are
subject to the rules
thank you in other words just an
automatic
as the studies get
done they get added to the list of
forbidden
chemicals
okay thank you let's keep the side
conversations to a minimum please the
noise level is getting a little high in
here representative
sorry about that representative lewicki
is recognized okay thank you mr chairman
um as someone who has done far too much
reading on pubmed and various other
places there are a lot of researchers
graduate students people doing research
on a lot of different things in a lot of
different places doing animal studies
doing in vitro studies and if we can
use their efforts to get to inform the
department then we will save money
because
we can only do a limited number of
studies in new hampshire and we don't
necessarily even know what we should be
looking for whereas if somebody can go
through the literature it's possible to
multiply our efforts at less cost
thank you representative mcgee
thank you mr chairman yeah um i just
wanted to mention i think the des air
quality person is here in the hearing
and she actually probably could answer
all the stuff that we're speculating
about in terms of what they
already know already do or what they
have in terms of an understanding of
like where we're at with
um this particular issue so if there are
questions it seems like people are
speculating about how we could approach
it but we our air quality person is here
in the room so
um
what they know how they'd get it whether
it would cost money i mean she could
probably answer any of those questions
would you be willing to answer questions
does anyone have a yeah you can have a
cookie while you're there does anyone
have a question for
and i'm sorry i forgot your name
miss beam
um anybody have a question
representative thomas
thank you mr chair i guess the obvious
question i would have is
is any of what is in this amendment now
is it
already being done by by des as a matter
of course
so the language that we're discussing
today is um an addition to our already
existing statute for air toxics control
and so we already have the ability to do
rule making
for
toxic emissions this just spells out
that pfas is another toxic that we would
want to evaluate studies that exist
nationwide this is not something that we
are conducting studies of it's simply
evaluating as one of the representatives
mentioned any other studies that are out
there
and inhalation studies are
not as prevalent as
ingestion studies of drinking water
that's a you know a much more studied
area this is just opening the door to
letting us evaluate what's out there and
potentially in the future adding a pfas
to the list of toxics
thank you
representative partial
thank you chair vause i'm looking at the
amendment and looks very similar to the
uh clause 5 of section 125 1 4 which you
probably know but i have to look it up
sorry
um but it seems like the only difference
really seems that
this is uh providing you with a mandate
by january 1st 2023 and annually
thereafter you will conduct a review
and that doesn't necessarily exist in
the legislation this is written now is
that correct
that's correct the legislation right now
requires us to evaluate certain
toxics that are on certain lists the
acgih american society of chemical and
industrial hygienists has a list of
compounds and we do that this just
explicitly points out pfas because
the section right above that you're
pointing out is is an open-ended if
somebody brings a compound to us to
evaluate this just explicitly makes it
thank you so much for that answer that's
good enough for me thank you
representative knotter has a question
thank you mr chairman um did you get a
chance to see the amendment
yes i worked with a representative boyd
on it okay and follow up
so if you do find it acceptable then the
department is is okay with it yes thank
you
additional questions representative
callie pitts
are you participating in the uh
commission that is formed by has been
formed by the state to evaluate
pfas and look to see if any of these
things because it says
in this amendment it says to determine
whether there exists at least one study
blah blah blah
that any individual pfas is known to
cause you know a problem or may
reasonably be anticipated to applaud
that has not none of that has been
substantiated
but are you are you involved in the
studies that are going on with pfas
right now
well i have
we have a representative on the
commission related to pfas and health
and environmental impacts um so whenever
there's an error-related question i'm
consulted if that's what you're asking
i i'm not actually participating in
inhalation studies at this point as one
of the representative mentioned it's a
scientific endeavor with you know
rodents and and inhalation
situation scientific studies they're not
necessarily just
evaluating i'm not familiar with what
studies you're referring to
all right
follow up there is a commission headed
and i believe it's headed by senator
sherman
and portsmouth right now on its own is
doing an air quality study an air
inhalation study as part of a pfas study
but this
implies that pfas is known to cause
and
i don't believe and
i know it's a serious thing and all
chemicals are serious
but i don't know if there is any
concrete evidence out there
that pfas
causes
it pollutes water that's most certain
there is a cancer cluster and my son
lives right near that cancer cluster
but and my grandson
but i don't know that there's actually a
cause and effect that's been established
which
this seems to do then there's an or in
there
but that first sentence says it does
cause
so again this language mimics the rest
of the statute now that says that we
look at toxic compounds in the
scientific studies and if they are found
a cause
right and so right now one of the pfas
compounds the ammonia salt of pfoa
is already on the air toxics list it was
what required zenkovein to reformulate
their compounds in 2006 so it's already
based on a study from from osha really
so on inhalation levels that are too
high for people to breathe so
there are work in the area of
ventilation
dust
but mostly it's it's through ingestion
of water that the studies have been
primarily focused on
further questions for des
seeing none i thank you very much for
being available to answer those
questions
so
is there any further discussion on the
adoption of this amendment
representative pimentel
thank you mr chairman i just wanted to
um
clarify something
this bill doesn't say that
pfass is known to cause these things
it's just saying the commissioner
um
has to review uh
whether there exists
a study
that demonstrates that any individual
pfas is known to cause they're just
saying that the commissioner has to look
to see if that exists not that it does
exist
thank you any further discussion
seeing none i asked the clerk to call
the role on the adoption of amendment
2022099
h to hb 1546
eight
zero eight nine nine eight yes
that's what i think
i had zero eight nine nine eight but i
heard something different from you thank
you sorry if i misspoke uh
representative thomas
yes representative harrington
yes representative notter yes
representative murder yes representative
platfors yes representative berezni yes
represent bernardi yes represent
campbells yes representative plosia yes
representative white yes representative
lewicki yes represent messimilla yes
excuse me
representative callie pitts
representative mann
representative oxendum
yes
representative harrigan yes represent
mcgee yes representative williams yes
representative heck and phillips yes
represent pimentel yes representative
partial yes and the chair yes 22-0 by a
vote of 22 to nothing the amendment
8099-h is adopted
we now
have the question of ought to pass as
adopted representative notter did you
move
that we
adopt this uh
hb 1546 as it as amended yes i move
ought to pass as amended representative
thomas second
moved and seconded that we adopt
hb 14 56 as amended by
zero eight nine nine h any further
discussion
seeing none as soon as you're ready mr
clerk you can call the roll
i shall
i just told my wife
wrong screen sorry
the roll call ought to pass as amended
for 1546 fn
uh representative thomas yes professor
of harrington yes representative notter
yes representative murder yes
representative platt votes yes
representative berezni yes
representative bernardi yes
representatives yes representative
pleasure yes representative white yes
representative wiki yes
representative massimila yes
representative kelly pitts
rep is a man yes
president
president again
uh yeah
getting there representative oxford i
know you're president yeah
representative oregon yes
but i'd like to vote
you did didn't you
i got that yes but you also voted
yes okay thank you representative mcgee
yes representative mcwilliams
yes
representative hacken phillips yes
representative pimentel yes
representative partial yes and the chair
yes 22-0 by a vote of 22 to nothing
house bill
is judged to be otp a
do we want this to be on the consent
calendar yes or no
no objection
it will be on consent
so i closed the public hearing of the
executive session on house bill
1546.
it is now
eleven past one we're scheduled to start
a work session at two o'clock
i think we can squeeze in one more bill
so
i will open the public the executive
session on house bill 1596
dash fn
and recognize representative bernardi
thank you mr chairman i move uh itl on
1596.
i represent uh recognize representative
cambrils
yes thank you mr chairman i would like
to second that motion
it's been moved and seconded that hb
1596-f
n
be judged to be itl is there any
discussion representative bernardi
thank you mr chairman uh yes uh this
this bill again raises the specter of
of transferring costs
in a socially regressive manner
to
non-customers
of
green energy uh
either solar or wind
in addition to that we had the
department of energy
indicate that they believe it's
appropriate to wait for
the current hearing in front of the
public utilities commission
on this issue
as as well as
looking at the experience that hb 315
demonstrates from expanding net metering
to
municipalities
further discussion on this question
of itl on hb 1596 representative mcgee
thank you mr chairman um i in the
description that i just heard i don't
recognize the bill that we're looking at
because my understanding is that
this is this would the only transfer
that would happen here would be for
people who are already
securing credits who have multiple
accounts
uh
it's not that bill
no that's that's a bill we uh
adjudicated yes oh this is never mind
then i'm gonna this is an expansion of
net metering to five megawatts
i can't a further discussion on this
bill
i'll remind the members that
a version of this bill has been vetoed
by the governor
three times over the course of the last
two years representative mick williams
thank you chair bows
just to to speak to net metering and the
desire for increased net metering in new
hampshire
this has been identified
at least amongst my constituents in
concord as a priority we are currently
moving to all renewable energy by uh
2030 which as the time passes that's
eight years from now it's coming quickly
and so for my constituents this is a
really big deal to allow individuals
small businesses developers you name it
to be able to increase from one to five
megawatts in order to net meter their
production so this is a big deal as i
said and it's important to keep bringing
it up and talking about it thank you
representative pimentel
thank you mr chairman
it was brought up that
this bill
was
looked upon
uh that
there is the viter study that is
supposed to be out this spring and that
we should wait until
uh that
uh study
is done uh because we're basically
uh we'd be able to look at this a little
more holistically
which i agree with and as you know there
are
several other bills that are coming up
which
got the same response that we should be
waiting
for
this vitar study to be completed
thank you further discussion of the
motion to itl uh this bill
representative horrigan is recognized
yes i'm just a guest here but i'm uh
my district includes one of the
municipalities that probably would be
affected by this because we have a large
solar array and we certainly um
that was uh the people of the town of
durham we were hoping to uh
hoping not just to save the costs of
burning fossil fuels to support the town
but we were hoping to
sell the energy to um to other entities
and i don't really see what's socially
regressive about that but maybe that's
because i'm a capitalist and i'll also
add
recent world events have shown
um
shown that uh it's dangerous to rely too
much on fossil fuels since one of our
major fossil fuel
providers is now like being
cut off from the rest of the world
global economy for uh you know because
they invaded another another sovereign
nation so i think i think anything
encourages social uh i think i think
anything that encourages renewable
energy such as solar is uh
not not regressive and i would support
it and and
after the i'm just guessing this
committee so i'm not as fair as they
should be with all these different
studies but i think certainly
until next year we should leave the law
the way it is and uh but we should
expand the law the way it is and uh we
should pass this bill so thanks
thank you any further discussion of the
motion to itl house bill 1596
representative partial
thank you chair rose
i support this bill very strongly
because i
unfortunately am shut out from being
able to afford a um
small solar system right now uh the
payback period is too long on it
and if we could increase that metering
it would make
so uh
acquiring solar technology much more
affordable for the average consumer and
that would mean more green jobs for the
state of new hampshire and it would also
mean more grid stability i really don't
see a downside on this i understand the
governor has vetoed it three times
however i see this is a good bill and
i'm
i plan on supporting it thank you so
much
thank you
any further discussion of this
question
seeing none i'd like to ask the clerk to
call the roll on the motion to itl house
bill
1596. representative thomas
yes president harrington yes
representative notter yes representative
murder yes representative pled votes yes
representative berezni yes
representative bernardi yes represent
cambrils yes representative pleasure yes
representative white yes representative
lewicki yes
representative messimilla no
represent cali pitts
pud
no thank you represent man no
represent oxygen no
represent horrigan no professor mcgee
nope representative mick williams
no representative heck and phillips no
representative pimentel
uh representative partial
and the chair
yes
thirteen to nine i have
okay by a
vote of 13 to nine
house bill
1596 has been judged to be itl
representative mcgee will there be a
minority amendment
a report
minority report representative williams
representative mick williams yep okay
need that by
end of day today if possible
all right with that we can close the
executive session on hb 1596
and
open the executive session on hb 1599
and on this i would like to recognize
representative plett for a motion
okay in one second
i'm i moved to uh
uh ought to pass on this on this bill
1599.
representative white is recognized i
second that
it's been moved and seconded that we
judge hb 1599 as
ought to pass
discussion on this question yes
yes mr chair i
support this bill because
right now uh people are being double
paid for uh if they sell
wrecks they're being double paid because
they get the money from the rex and they
also get it in in
uh what they're paid by the utilities
for default service so
the the part of the default service that
includes
uh the
cost to consumers of the wrecks should
not be included so they don't get double
paid
further discussion on this motion
representative mcgee
thank you mr chairman
yeah i actually went through the bill
last night because i was doing the
minority report and i think the point
that i would make is that this this real
really feels very much like rate setting
uh from the house in a way that um
it may make sense with some people's
simple math but i don't think it
reflects
uh the complexity of the rate setting
that has been used to try and establish
the rps credits the alternative
compliance payments system benefits
charge all of these are
well considered and long reviewed and as
we have alluded to a couple of times
we have been told that there the der
study through the puc for the value of
distributed energy resources is due this
spring
and so
uh
taking a stab at trying to figure out
what someone's opinion is of what this
rate should be
and just eliminating uh rates that have
been considered when they were set i i
just think it's very irresponsible for
us to just
i mean i don't know whose decision this
is or who decided that this was the way
to approach it but it isn't what has
been considered by those people who've
been responsible for rate setting in the
state of new hampshire
it's a departure from that process and i
very much oppose it
thank you the
the testimony of the honorable clifton
below from the city of lebanon
uncovered that the tariff that's been in
place since 2017
and he was an intervener in the docket
that established that tariff
created what he called a missing money
problem
he further characterized the missing
money problem
this way it's he said the missing money
has to be made up by other customers
resulting in an undue cost shift or
subsidy
so mr bilo actually created the
language of this
bill
and
proposed it last
spring when we were doing the
committee of conference on house bill
the
senate did not want to accept this
language at that time
but
commissioner former commissioner belo
made a strong case
that
the missing money problem
is an undue cost shift to
non-net metering customers and the way
to rectify that is by adopting the
language of this
proposed legislation
uh representative oxenam has a comment
thank you very much mr chair um
a number a number of issues there
when
assistant mayor below spoke to this
committee at the public hearing
he raised many points
as as he often does
and the the missing money of he quoted
uh in the city of lebanon
is something like sixty thousand dollars
in terms of the renewable portfolio
compliance costs which are included in
which he felt should not be legitimately
but also at the same time we're more
than offset by a hundred and twenty
thousand dollars in the avoided
transmission costs which are a positive
benefit
so that this this is why regulated
regulation rate setting is complicated
there are many things which offset each
other there are many things which
compound each other and that's why we
hire professionals to do the work
we've all agreed that we should wait for
the vder study but i i will only add one
more point here which is that when the
utilities purchase energy they don't go
out and buy at the locational marginal
price they hire suppliers those
suppliers put a lot of different costs
which brings it up from the locational
marginal price to what we call the
default service price there are things
in there like hedging there are things
in there like the renewable portfolio
compliance costs there's avoided
transmission costs almost all of those
costs between the locational marginal
price and the default service price
are avoided
by
customer generators because they put out
energy which never gets to that meter
where the wholesale where our the grid
intersects
those cause it's load reduction it's
it's unseen
energy and therefore it reduces costs
and that is the most significant reason
why this bdr study has been
so important and why we should wait to
take any action on this
um
of this bill thank you
representative harrington
yeah there's a lot of stuff going on
here um
let's just start with the simple part of
this this is we're trying to
overcomplicate this the people that get
paid for net metering have a rate that
we call default service and it was just
mentioned by the previous speaker the
default service is very complicated it
involves the price of the energy
but it also that the utility has to buy
but it also involves having the utility
have to set up a bidding process and a
review process and put out bids select
those bids take those bids to the puc
all of those costs are put into default
service rates then the supplier they
select also has costs one of them is
profits because they wouldn't be in the
business if it wasn't for making profits
you they mentioned hedging that's the
risk factor that's probably one of the
highest uh
components of this i've talked to people
who actually negotiate these contracts
and they tell me somewhere in the range
of 40 percent of the total cost of
default service is the risk factor of
that supplier being having to go on an
hourly basis almost a minute to minute
basis matching supply and demand so if
they happen to be
i'll just use next era for an example
who's a supplier and one of the com
places they tend to get power from is
seabrook but seabird trips offline they
can't call eversource or or liberty up
and say sorry we're not going to have
much power today because one of our
suppliers tripped offline no no they
have to go buy it someplace else and
that's a huge risk premium all of that
is built into the default service rate
one of the other things that's built
into it is the compliance with the
renewable portfolio standard the
supplier of the electricity utility has
to buy these these green wrecks or make
alternative compliance payments now the
person doing net metering is also
getting paid green racks so they're
getting the green wrecks as as pieces of
paper that they can then sell because
the utilities are forced to buy it and
they're also getting a higher default
service rate because the cost of
compliance is already included in there
all this bill does is say no double
payment we're not going to we're not
going to allow you to to acquire green
rex for every megawatt of electricity
you produce and then pay you a rate
based on the utilities compliance with
green rex it just ends the double
payment it's really quite simple
thank you further discussion
representative lewicki is recognized um
thank you mr chairman i actually have a
question relative to line eight
where it says including prior period
reconciliation shall be deducted from
the monetary credit
i'm wondering whether this is actually a
clawback or whether i'm misreading it
repeat the line that did you have a
question about
uh line eight um it says including prior
period reconciliation shall be deducted
from the monetary credit for exports to
the grid
and i it is uncle i may be reading it
wrong but i'm wondering whether this is
a clawback or an exposed facto clause um
and perhaps someone can clarify
representative plat
yes it's not a clawback what the prior
period reconciliation is simply
uh is that they put in a
dollar amount to the puc
for a six-month period
and that it includes all that stuff that
representative harrington just talked
about
then they go out and they build that for
the six months
trying to recover what they thought the
cost was
but if their estimate is a little wrong
then the prior period reconciliation
just say okay we were a little wrong in
the last six months we were we
overcharged by a hundred thousand for
example we'll give that hundred thousand
dollars a credit for our next estimate
that's all
or if it's undercharged by a hundred
thousand they throw the hundred thousand
in to recover the undershoot
okay further discussion of this question
representative pementel
thank you mr chairman i just think that
this bill is only looking at one side of
the ledger
and that
that is the reason we need to wait
for the uh values
distribution energy resources study to
come out in the spring
which is looking at both sides of the of
the ledger and involving
[Music]
both the
suppliers and the
and the producers
to
to get
an equitable
price
for the energy they produce and i think
that
uh i just think it's premature to be
doing this now and just like the
previous bill
we should wait for this study to be
completed
and
get a more equitable
uh
price
of
this distributed this
electric energy being being produced
thank you i hope everyone's not
confusing this bill which tries to
correct a mistake that was made when the
tariff was set back in 2017
and the bill we'll just be discussing
later on this afternoon 1629
which is a bill to change the definition
of default service those
two bills are different things they
attempt to do
different things
although there is one component that
they both do
but the intense
of each bill is different
so i would urge you not to confuse the
two
representative representative horgans
has his hand up oh thank you very much
mr chair and i apologize i know i'm just
a guest in this committee so a lot of
the
details i'm not up to speed on but i've
got
this um
same concerns i had with the previous
bill first of all from a parochial level
uh my town government is i'm pretty sure
one of the
producers of renewable energy we have a
large solar
installation owned by the town of durham
so we appear to be one of the targets of
this that they are trying to reduce
the subsidies
um they're trying to raise the cost of
that renewable energy or at least you
know lower the benefit we get from
replacing fossil fuel usage and then
also jumping to a global
global thing the uh
i think we're going to have to accept
that the cost of fossil fuels is
probably going to have to be higher than
it was in the past for various reasons
including the fact that we're having
a war
in a major fossil fuel producing area
and um
we're bringing
sanctions against russia and that's not
under our control that's probably an
issue
most of us do not want to talk about at
all but that's uh that's
thank you representative yes what the
fossil fuel economy is the fossil fuel
economy i think is is going to have to
change yes and it's probably going to
cost more and renewables will cost less
so um
i apologize for anybody's feelings but i
that's what i believe and i think we're
not here to discuss
ukrainian russian politics of course not
i understand
net figuring
and to correct your misunderstanding
this bill does not
deprive the citizens of durham in any
way in fact
as the honorable clifton below
testified before this committee
it
removes
an undue cost shift
to non-net metering customers that's
what this bill
accomplishes representative oxenum
thank you very much mr chair
as i said earlier mr bilo said several
things when he was here before the
committee
and he said that this issue of the
missing money the sixty thousand dollars
that lebanon pays because britain
of the compliance costs being factored
into the default service rate
was a minor issue but it was one that he
felt legitimately should be addressed
and he contrasted it in his remarks with
a hundred and twenty thousand dollars
twice that which works in the opposite
direction which is money that is
unfairly
benefiting lebanon because of
the the
renewable generation so
it it's very important if you're going
to quote him that you quote him on both
sides as he said
net metering from the outset was rough
justice it it was not a mathematical
formula and it has been undergone
changes over time
but the
idea that default service
is is double counting is absolutely
wrong
the community power arrangements which
are now being finalized across the state
use the default service rate because it
is a it is an accurate portrayal
of the benefits to net meter they have
no responsibility they're not utilities
they're not required
to have a net metering but they are
voluntarily doing net metering because
this is an appropriate sum and again
that program was designed and this
funding was designed by cliff below so
we we must be very careful to to
um include both the the counter and the
po the positive and the negative because
as
we've been told again and again rate
making is complicated and so when you
try to pull one thing out you can upset
an arrangement where by which you you
have things that are in rough balance
thank you
i would agree with you that we need to
take take great care
and i would also point out that
it's likely you don't know this because
you weren't there but during the lipa
study commission hearings
we were told that
there is no
data to support
that
avoided transmission costs can be
monetized
the iso new england doesn't think they
can be monetized the department of
energy has doubts that they can be
monetized
so to characterize
the honorable clifton bilo's testimony
as attributing 120 000
uh to the city as a cross subsidy
because of avoided transmission charges
may not be true because
we don't know until the value of der
study comes out whether or not avoided
transmission charges
are real we also don't know whether
well i'll leave it at that but until
that study comes out we don't even know
that avoided transmission charges are
monetizable if that's a word
so i wouldn't go so far as to say that
not making this change which will save
60 000 in the case of the city of
lebanon and much more across the entire
state
for
ratepayers
due to undue cost shifting i wouldn't
say that that's the negligible
benefit that is a
substantial benefit and we owe it to the
customers the ratepayers in our state to
give them that benefit
representative mcgee
sorry lee did you want him
um
okay
so
um
i what i'm hearing i mean when i hear
representative pimentel saying you know
it's premature i think that that's where
i fall on this as well
my question would be why would we be
doing this at this point because
we're
we're sort of rolling with the
assumption that there's some cost
shifting that's happening which we also
don't have
any proof of because the study hasn't
been completed in terms of the value
that's being provided by these producers
and what this bill does is it reaches in
and it
reduces an existing
credit that's available by the amount of
the rps compliance so it's doing two
things it's lowering what's in the rps
funding for supporting projects around
the state and it's also devaluing the
current proposition that people who have
these facilities
are
are receiving for the value of their
product and all of that is being done by
people who have no background in rate
setting and that's that i mean my my
exception is just that it's a bad bill
it just doesn't make any sense for us to
be doing this
you seem to be confusing this bill with
house bill 1629 all this bill does is
correct a mistake that was made back in
2017 that's according to
clifton below zone test by removing the
rps compliance payment
by removing the double payment
of rps to net metering customers yes
representative platt
i was wondering if it's time to move on
i think it's been discussed to death
is there anyone else who would like to
contribute to the discussion
seeing none
then i will ask the clerk to call the
roll on the question of ought to pass on
house bill 1599.
representative thomas
yes representative harrington yes
representative notter yes representative
murder yes representative platt votes
yes representative berezni yes
representative bernardi yes represent
cambrils yes represent yes
representative white yes representative
lewicky yes representative messimilla no
representative kelly pitts
representative mann
representative oxenam
no
representative oregon no problem mcgee
no representative mcwilliams no
professor heck and phillips
no representative pimentel
representative partial
and the chair yes
i have 13 nine
by a vote of 13 to 9 hb 1599
is judged to be ought to pass will there
be representative mcgee a minority
report yes
it will be written by and it will be
rewritten by me
by you yes i submitted it this morning
but i'm going to rewrite it
i haven't checked my email since very
early this morning
just trying to get it off my plate
okay by a vote of
13 to 9 that bill is passed
let's see is there another bill we can
do here in 20 minutes
all right
so let's close the exact session on
1599 and open an exact station on house
bill 1628.
directing the department of energy to
director
to generate a report on the micro grid
project currently in progress at the
university of new hampshire i recognize
representative clausier thank you mr
chair i'd like to
motion to itl
house bill 1628.
okay
i'd like to recognize representative
lewicki uh thank you mr chairman i uh
second the motion okay it's been moved
and seconded that we itl house bill 1628
do we have any discussion
okay
apparently not
okay mr clerk if you're ready would you
call the the role i indeed am ready
uh itl 1628 representative thomas
yes representative harrington yes
representative notter yes representative
mirner yes representative platt votes
yes representative berezni yes
bernardi yes representative campbells
yes representative pleasure yes
representative white yes representative
wiki yes representative massa miller yes
but i gotta fix your spelling again
representative kelly pitts
represent a man
representative oxendum
yes
representative horrigan
no
uh representative mcgee
yes
representative mcwilliams no
representative hacken phillips
yes
representative pimentel
represent partial
representative pasha
and the chair yes
i have uh
it's
19-3
okay by a vote of to 3 hb 1628 fn is
judged to be itl
will there be any kind of minority
report
no okay
so
with that we'll close the public hearing
on i mean the
executive session on 1628
and we'll see if we can squeeze in one
more before the work session so i'm
going to
open the exact session on house bill
and i'll recognize representative excuse
me mr chairman point of order
point of order yeah um
i hate to bring this up but on the last
bill 1628 there was an amendment that
came out i don't know what the status of
that was it was uh
2022-2047h
i have an answer for that okay l
we itl at the amendment is moot okay
great okay thank you
representative white is now recognized
for a motion on h.b 1635
thank you mr chairman um i'd like to
move uh interim study for this bill
representative mirner is recognized yes
i'd like to second
representative white
moves that we submit hb
1635 fn to interim study
and i will start the discussion by
mentioning that
during the public hearing for this bill
i asked representative mcgee who is its
prime sponsor if she would be amenable
to an amendment
to implement one or more of the
recommendations of the lipa study
committee commission
study commission report and she said she
would be amenable to that
so i contacted the department of energy
to discuss with them
what
that amendment should look like
and the department of energy told me
that
this question is going to be studied
adequately in the vder study that is
about to be released
sometime this spring
so as a result
they advised me not to make an amendment
to
open a new docket at the puc to
do yet another study
because they assured me that the vder
study would probably provide the answers
that we're looking for
so as a result i suggested that interim
study would be a good outcome for this
bill so that's
why we're at where we are now is there
any further discussion
representative callie pitts
i
i agree with you that this bill should
be put off but i'm wondering why interim
study because interim study
implies that we are going to bring
this back in another form in the
following year and really study it over
the summer
and if the study is being con
you know completed now or in progress
now
why would we study it
again this summer i
don't understand that
well i'll refresh your memory that in
the second year of a biennium
interim study
typically means that
you refer a bill
either to recommend it for additional
legislation or not recommend it for
additional
legislation
so if we wait for the vder study to come
out
we can then pass judgment on whether
this bill should be
should recommend
future legislation or not
so interim study seems like the
appropriate way to go
as a result of that i hope that answers
your question
any further discussion
while seeing none i'll ask the clerk to
call the role on the motion of interim
study on hb 1635. representative thomas
yes professor harrington yes
representative yes representative murder
yes representative platforms yes
representative perez yes represent
bernardi yes representative campbell's
yes represent yes representative white
yes represent yes representative
massimilia yes
represent cali pits
represent man no
rexella oxram
yeah
represent of oregon
no
problem mcgee
yes
representative mcwilliams yes
representative
heck and phillips yes president pimentel
representative partial yes
and the chair yes
i have eighteen to four
i have a void a vote of 18 to four
house bill 1635 is recommended for
interim study
with that i close the exact session on
house bill 1635
and i will put our committee into recess
until two o'clock
at which time we will undertake a full
committee work session on house bill
1645.
we will exec that bill as soon as we're
done with the full committee work
session
and then we will exec hb
1629 which will be our final bill of the
day
so please return to your seats by two
o'clock thank you
okay folks time to get back to work
so let's have a full committee work
session on house bill 1645.
this uh work session was requested by
representative oxenam
and so i'm going to
yield the floor to representative
oxidant for some kind of a presentation
it's all yours
thank you very much and thank you
colleagues i really appreciate your
indulgence in making uh this time
available at
the end of the day for
a bill which i i think is of salient
importance to to all of us
i'd just like to remind you of a few
things from the public hearing i
declared a conflict a possible conflict
of interest at that time
i have discussed this with the lawyers
here at the state capitol and it is
permitted for me to discuss the bill it
is permitted for me to vote in committee
on the bill but just as last year
the i had declared a conflict of
interest on the floor when a similar
bill was going to be heard but was not
heard
i will not vote on the floor of the
house on this bill
okay so uh you have before you
a
handout
wreck sweeping and unconstitutional
taking
and you have before you an amendment
again i've handed out the amendment at
the time of the public hearing the
reason for the
amendment which replaces the entirety of
the original bill
is that at the time of drafting back
when we had our window for lsrs i was
under the mistaken apprehensive
apprehension
that i could not bring back the original
bill because it had been introduced in
the prior session
it was one of the bills that went off
into the nether netherlands because we
didn't get to it
on the floor and because it wasn't acted
on the floor actually it was possible to
bring the original text before you so
what you have here
in the amendment is the bill that we
would have considered on the floor of
the house last spring
and what what it does is it says that
the
practice of wreck sweeping is
unconstitutional it constitutes a taking
of property and it should be removed
from statute
the original bill when we didn't think
we could bring that forward
was a an itemization of how you could
notify consumers that they were being
harmed and how they could protect
themselves from the harm of the practice
of rec sweeping
so um
i will try to move through this quickly
and i think i can we've covered some of
this before
for some of you it will be a little bit
familiar
and i would appreciate it if people
could just note down their questions and
we gets them at the end i think that way
we'll we'll all get through this um
hopefully in in
record time
okay so there's a brief synopsis that
lays out the the general
uh landscape
a uh list on page two of the key harms
of rec sweeping first of all it denies
the owners of renewable energy of the
right to use i'm sorry it's called slide
three
i was not counting the cover page thank
you very much for the correction
denies the owners of renewable energy
the right to use their own property it
denies the right of renewable energy
owners to exclude others from using
their property it places citizens and
businesses who generate renewable energy
in jeopardy of criminal prosecution
either a misdemeanor or a felony
conviction for claiming to use their own
renewable energy
and it transfers millions of dollars of
wealth from predominantly middle class
new hampshire residents and businesses
to out-of-state multi-billion dollar
corporations
so a little glance back at the rps
program state rps programs require
electricity providers to acquire and
supply renewable energy to their
customers
it is physically impossible to track
particular electron flows on a shared
electrical grid
no one can determine who's using the
physical electricity produced by any
given generator whether it's renewable
or otherwise so a mechanism had to be
developed to track and trade renewable
energy independently of the physical
electricity
so this brings us to renewable
attributes
physical attributes of something we're
familiar with renewable attributes what
this means is
what makes renewable energy renewable so
it's renewableness they're sometimes
also referred to in statute as
environmental attributes
so renewable attributes are created
whenever renewable energy is generated
they are created at the same moment as
the electrons
they are property specifically they are
intangible property
renewable energy certificates what we
know of as wrecks are simply legal
instruments designed to represent and
convey ownership of those renewable
attributes
so the invention of rex enabled
renewable attributes to be separated or
unbundled from the original megawatt
hours and to be reassigned or bundled
with other megawatt hours
so this invention
and this reassignment led to a change in
the legal definition of what constitutes
renewable energy
a megawatt hour of renewable energy is
now defined as any megawatt hour that is
bundled with a renewable attribute
regardless of the kind of power plant
that generated it so if a coal-fired
power plant produces a megawatt hour of
energy and they buy a wreck
that is renewable energy
and what you produced with your solar
array at home if you sold that wreck
is now
null
electricity
and if you claim it
as renewable energy you are subject to
felony or misdemeanor prosecution if
it's done in a commercial arrangement
such as selling your home or
claiming that your own factory is run by
renewable power
so when you lose your renewable
attributes
you lose your renewable energy
renewable attribute unbundling created
the need for strict anti-double counting
rules at both the state and federal
levels you can't have your cake and eat
it too if you sell your wrecks
that you you've lost title you've lost
ownership of your renewable energy
under the rules a customer generator
must retain exclusive rights to the
renewable attributes they create in
order to legally possess
and claim to use the renewable energy
they actually generate a customer
generator who gives up their renewable
attributes by selling wrecks
transfers ownership of that property to
the buyer
and i read this particular not this one
at the public hearing the ability of an
organization to make claims of using
green power is contingent upon its
ownership of the renewable attributes
associated with the electricity it
consumes an organization must ensure it
possesses exclusive and full rights to
the wrecks or renewable attributes
associated with its electricity
consumption to make environmental claims
this rule applies in all cases whether
the organization owns the renewable
system or is purchasing the green power
from a third party and that comes from
the us department of energy's guide to
purchasing green power
i read to you at the public hearing
about the toy manufacturer i'll just
read the bolded section
even if the manufacturer uses the
electricity generated by the solar
panels on the factory it has by selling
the wrecks
transferred the right to characterize
that electricity as renewable
the manufacturer's claim is therefore
deceptive
and by ftc guidelines you could be
charged ten thousand dollars a day
for this violation
ras exist even in the absence of wrecks
this is where it gets a little bit
tougher as federal and state courts have
recognized ras are created whenever
renewable energy is generated and they
existed before wrecks were invented to
represent them
this is a quote from the connecticut
supreme court the renewable attribute of
the energy generated by renewable energy
sources is an inherent attribute of the
energy and therefore the creation and
state recognition of rex did not result
in an entirely new commodity but in the
splitting of a pre-existing commodity
new hampshire statutory law also
recognizes that renewable attributes
exist in the absence of wrecks guidance
documents from the u.s department of
energy and the epa expressly recognize
that renewable attribute property
interests exist regardless of whether
wrecks are issued the pucs in multiple
new england states recognize this fact
and i'll just take you very briefly
through a little bit of new hampshire's
statutory law
rsa 374 f 3 v
f establishes that property interest and
renewable attributes exist regardless of
whether they are represented by rex
it does so specifically providing for
the voluntary buying and selling of
renewable energy source attributes
these are produced by generators that
would quote qualify to receive renewable
energy certificates
under
rsa 362f
regardless of whether they have actually
registered for or been issued wrecks
under rsa
362f if renewable energy source
attributes can be bought and sold
regardless of whether they are
represented by wrecks
clearly they are property
regardless of whether they are
represented by rex or not
i'm sorry
and the federal guidance here even if
the renewable energy project is not
formally registered with and issued
wrecks from a regional tracking system
the renewable project still generates
the renew the environmental attributes
these environmental attributes can be
sold or transferred to other parties
through contractual agreements so
you can even buy and sell them
without having the legal representation
of a wreck they are property you can
transfer them by contract
if the generator is not registered with
a wreck tracking system and therefore
wrecks are not formally issued within a
tracking system the generator
nevertheless creates energy attributes
with every megawatt hour generated
now it was suggested at the public
hearing that oh all you really need to
do is register your wrecks if you were
only to register your wrecks you would
be protected
well
i'll try to make this simple and clear
rex represent and convey the property
interest
the renewable attribute property
interest exists regardless of whether or
not they are represented by rex so when
customer generators register for
and are issued wrecks they're not
claiming any new property they're merely
completing a process of registering
something they already own
in order to qualify it for sale in the
rps compliance market
now you can say well why not just
register
it's expensive it's time consuming it's
an intrusion on your privacy and it's
burdensome where in the world do we
require anyone to do such a thing just
to protect their property from being
seized and used by others
so
registering to have your ras be
represented by rex can cost about two
thousand dollars for the typical
customer generator who's already
interconnected before you can even
submit an application for wreck
registration you have to install a
specialized production meter you have to
hire an independent monitor and over
time that can cost over a thousand
dollars
installing the production meter requires
hiring an electrician to install a
specialized electrical socket for the
production meter that you are not even
going to use
then purchasing and having the actual
meter installed for another six hundred
dollars for something you're not even
going to use
customer generators can only submit an
application for rec registration after
they complete all of these steps the
application requires voluminous amounts
of personal and technical information
plus six or more supplemental documents
okay finally wreck sweeping
no because some people aren't following
up just let them know what page so they
can keep up page 19.
rsa362f62a enables electricity providers
to meet some of their rps obligations by
using the renewable attributes of
customer generators who did not undergo
the time consuming and expensive process
required for wreck registration we call
this practice wreck sweeping it's really
renewable attribute sweeping but
it's known as rec sweeping
more specifically the state seizes
renewable attributes from customer
generators and lets electricity
providers claim
wreck credits
that represent a share of these seized
or swept renewable attributes
electricity providers can then use the
rec credits that represent these swept
renewable attributes for rps compliance
what's the problem
this constitutes a wholesale denial of
customer generators right to exclude
electricity providers from the use of
their renewable attributes
customer generators subject direct
sweeping lack the exclusive rights to
their renewable attributes which renders
them
which renders their generation
null electricity under federal guidance
you can't have the electricity providers
claim to use the renewable attributes
and still retain the renewable
attributes that would be double counting
that would be fraudulent activity
rsa 358a2 contains language modeled
after section 5a1 of the ftc act that
prohibits any unfair or deceptive actor
practice in the conduct of any trade or
commerce within the state rsa 358 a 13
provides that new hampshire courts may
be guided by the interpretation and
construction given section 5a1 by the
ftc when construing rsa 358 a2
as the ftc has found that claiming null
electricity is in renewable energy is
deceptive
and does violate section 5a1
doing so likely also violates rsa 358a2
at least when such claims affect
commerce such as if you were to
advertise the home you're selling as
solar powered or if you were to claim
that you're in your factory was
producing its product with renewable
energy rsa 358 a6 provides that a
natural person who violates rsa 3582 is
guilty of a misdemeanor and any business
entity doing so is guilty of a felony
rendering affected customer generators
who claim to use the renewable energy
they generate subject
sub liable to criminal prosecution under
new hampshire law
so
wreck sweeping is a taking
rec sweeping deprives customer
generators of both the right to use
their renewable attributes and the right
to exclude electricity providers from
using their renewable attributes such a
material abridgement of both the right
to use and exclude
constitutes a taking and this quote is
from the new hampshire supreme court
which the bold
reiterates a finding in 1872
this was handed down in 1981.
the property owner's right of indefinite
user or of using indefinitely in more
modern parlance
necessarily includes the right to
exclude others from using the property
whether it be in land or anything else
from the very nature of these rights of
user and of exclusion it is evident that
they cannot be materially abridged
without ipso facto taking the owner's
property
by taking i'm sorry moving on to
slide 22 by taking the renewable
attributes rec sweeping takes the
renewable energy recall from the very
beginning the definition of renewable
energy is any energy that is bundled
with the renewable attributes
when you strip the renewable attributes
from the customer generators electricity
you render it null electricity
rec sweeping thus deprives the affected
customer generator of the renewable
energy that they generate and own
consumers have an additional interest in
preventing their renewable attributes
from being used for rps compliance
many consumers choose to purchase or
generate their own renewable energy
because they want to increase overall
renewable energy generation beyond the
minimal levels set by the state's rps
statute
ensuring such additionality requires
preventing electricity providers from
using the ras that others generate and
own
for their rps compliance
many customer generators intentionally
choose not to register for and sell recs
in an effort to ensure that their
renewable attributes are not in fact
used for renewable portfolios compliance
for this very reason
both the federal and new hampshire law
recognize that those who want to be
voluntary renewable energy consumers
have what is called a consumer interest
beyond the property interest they have a
consumer interest in doing so
a couple quick quotes when consumers
choose to purchase or produce green
power above and beyond what is required
or otherwise available they do so
because they want to make a difference
that goes beyond what would have
otherwise occurred through a mandate or
as part of business as usual that's from
the doe's guide to purchasing green
power
consequently quote a long-standing
consumer requirement of the voluntary
market is that individual investments in
and use of green power do not go towards
supporting a mandate that would have
otherwise occurred absent the voluntary
consumers proactive use of green power
so the point here is
not only do renewable energy generators
because customer generators want to use
their own renewable energy they want to
add to the total amount of renewable
energy in the state
new hampshire law expressly recognizes
this consumer interest
a utility shall provide to its customers
one or more renewable energy source
options as approved by the commission
which may include res default service
provided by the utility or the provision
of retail access to competitive sellers
of res attributes
for purposes of consumer protection and
the maintenance of program integrity
reasonable efforts should be made to
assure that the renewable energy source
component of an res option is not
separately advertised claimed or sold as
part of any other electricity service or
transaction
including compliance with the renewable
portfolio standard
okay we're getting to the end here
it's been suggested that ref renewable
energy fund
rebates provide just compensation for
wreck sweeping this is false
there is no link between receiving a
rebate and being subject to wreck
sweeping
many customer generators who received a
b are not subject to wreck sweeping
while many who did not receive a rebate
are subject to wreck sweeping
just to make this a little clearer
approximately three thousand solar
customer generators who did receive a
rebate were not subject to wreck
sweeping as of 2020 and approximately a
thousand solar customer generators who
did not receive a rebate were subject
direct sweeping the rps statute provides
that those who receive an raf rebate
retain any wrecks they are issued and
thus ownership of the ras they represent
customer generators who received a
rebate and then register and sell their
ras as rex appropriately receive
additional money for doing so
but the customer generator who is swept
receives nothing
no compensation
net metering does not provide just
compensation for rec sweeping these are
two separate programs net metering only
compensates customer generators for
their exported
electricity the addition after they use
what as much as they need of their own
generation
whereas rec sweeping strips the
renewable attributes from all the
electricity that customer generators
generate
including what they consume behind the
meter
this is because it's a
a mathematical formula you take the size
of the array
you multiply it by the comp um
the the factor
helped me out michael the
capacity factor the capacity factor
thank you and so it's the size times the
capacity factor times the number of
hours in the year so it's everything
that your system is capable of producing
if it spent six months under a blanket
of snow and didn't produce anything
renewable attributes are attributed to
electricity providers even in the
absence
it's a remarkable system
customer generators who are not subject
direct sweeping can retain or sell their
renewable attributes for additional
money while those subject direct
sweeping cannot
and this may be one of the most
important points of all roughly half of
all the swept renewable attributes are
not going to utilities they are have no
effect on rate payers
much less actually
reducing what they pay
because
roughly half 48 percent
our electricity providers are big
multinational corporations like
constellation energy and direct energy
so the state is seizing the property of
new hampshire citizens and it is
allocating that benefit to big out of
state
multinational corporations who then can
do whatever they want with the money
they save because they don't have to pay
renewable
compliance payments they can give it to
their shareholders they can reinvest it
uh swept aris are not abandoned property
we covered that at the public hearing
allocation of swept areas to competitive
suppliers i just covered that
so we really are coming to the end
pennies for the typical rate payer
because 52 percent does go to the
utilities
pennies
and millions of dollars for corporations
as the result of state action in seizing
the property of new hampshire residents
and
businesses
rex sweeping possibly saves the typical
residential utility rate payer about six
cents in a typical month
yet rec sweeping saved competitive
suppliers many millions of dollars in
the period of its existence since 2012.
as i said constellation energy and
direct energy are subsidiaries of
out-of-state multi-billion dollar
corporations so the most significant
economic effect of rec sweeping has been
to transfer millions of dollars of
wealth from predominantly middle class
new hampshire residents to out-of-state
multi-billion dollar corporations
it is an unconstitutional policy that
has enriched those corporations
and at the expense of our residents that
we are here to protect without
compensation
and without notice
wreck sweeping prohibits affected
customer generators from using their own
property for their own intended purposes
whether that is to simply be able to
generate and use renewable energy or if
it is to create additional renewable
energy in the state beyond the minimal
requirements
rec sweeping bars
residents and our businesses from
claiming to use the renewable energy
they produce even if they use a hundred
percent of the corresponding physical
electricity themselves
on pain of criminal prosecution
please support overturning this
provision
thank you and i'll take questions
thank you do we have questions for uh
representative oxen and representative
platt yes and i'll let you covered what
did you cover that was not in your in
the public hearing because i thought you
covered all of this then
that in particular i was asked and the
department of energy sent an email and
said that they wanted specifics of the
rsas
that
actually backed up what i was saying so
the material that i have presented today
is to demonstrate
that in law and in guidance and in the
conduct of pucs
renewable attributes are treated as what
they are legally they are property and
if that property
is taken
without notice and without compensation
that is a taking
it's
i have a question
on slides
and 14
these
phrases
appear on on page or slide 11
inherent attribute and then on slide
environmental attribute
and then below that energy attribute
what are the differences between those
attributes thank you very much for the
question there's no difference and it's
it's a a real problem uh that these
different terms are used for the exact
same thing
and in some of the guidance they'll
actually even use rex and renewable
attributes as meaning the same thing
which gives a false impression if you
read the entire document it's clear that
they distinguish between the two but
every once in a while they'll use the
wrong term
and
yeah
okay thank you follow-up question
on slide 20.
the next to the last bullet says that a
business entity that does so meaning
wreck sweeping
is guilty of a felony
has the new hampshire attorney general
arrested any of the
state's utilities for committing these
felonies
the felony would be the business owner
who claims to use renewable energy
and makes that claim in a commercial so
advertising
or in the sale of their premises
that claim is a deceptive practice by
the ftc and it has been incorporated
into the statutes here in the state
such that you are liable to this uh
penalty of ten thousand dollars a day if
you're a business
and it's simply a misdemeanor if you are
a
an individual or a household
but to my knowledge it has not been
utilized
and uh
the the reason to point it out is not
because i think it should be
penalized but to demonstrate the fact
that this is a
practice which is
putting our citizens and businesses in
jeopardy
of violation of law
so as a third follow-up are you saying
that rec sweeping is not a criminal
activity
wreck sweeping itself is a pernicious
practice but not criminal
okay thank you further questions for
representative oxen i'm representative
mcgee thank you mr chairman
this says that effective data that shall
take effect upon its passage and i was
just wondering if there is
if this action is taken which changes a
process that's currently
the way things work
whether there would be any
administrative changes that would need
to happen in order for that to be
to make it effective immediately
i i'll ask representative harrington to
i don't think we have
would you have a doe person in in the
room it's my understanding that the way
rex sweeping's done is that it's at the
end of a year that it's a retroactive
look and then so so what this would do
is say don't do this from now on uh so
in our place june when when they make
this reconciliation so that it would
that that would be the effective time so
they'd have time to get it
you know and to stop doing something is
doesn't really require much
administrative change
representative pimentel
thank you mr chairman uh i guess this is
a question about process i'm looking at
slide 28 on
the
net metering does not provide just
compensation
and
it says that the
the state
does the sweeping is that correct it's
not the utilities
and do they it used to be done by karen
crampton at the puc
um she's no longer with the state and
the puc uh i would believe that has
transferred this function to the
department of energy
and a follow-up question does the state
then sell these
they just give them away they
it in effect they credit so
where where the utilities and the
electricity providers have a compliance
obligation if you they take the state
says hey you can just we'll we will
provide this to you we will seize this
and give it to you as a credit
and that's how it works
again it's an intangible property so
it's not like anything physical has to
happen there are no wrecks that are
changing hands
so this statute that governs this which
is the statute that this
amendment would repeal
which is
rsa 362 f
colon 6 2a
says and i quote by february 28th of
each year the department of energy cell
shall compute and make public credit
percentages
that are equal to the estimated
production for the prior calendar year
in each class
divided by the total amount of
electricity supplied by providers of
electricity to induce customers in the
prior calendar year
with the result converted to a
percentage
each provider may then
at the time of its annual report filing
under re
uh rsa 362f colon 8
claim a class 1 and a class 2
certificate credit equal to the credit
percentage times the total metal
megawatt hours of electricity supplied
by the provider
to its induced customers for the prior
calendar year so that's the mechanism by
which
so-called wreck sweeping happens
clear as mud
and
so
it is the department of energy or the
state
um used to be the poc of course but no
it's department of energy
that
essentially calculates
those percentages and then it allows
the providers the utilities
either the competitive suppliers or the
you the utilities
when they make their
wreck filings with the department
to
claim class one and class two
or sweep if you will
class one and class two certificates
that are unused or unclaimed so
it's um
it doesn't allow the sweeping of class
three or class four rex just class one
and class two rex
representative partial
yes i'm not i'm unclear in a couple
things here
um
with insufficient racks
it means any of these uh
producers would
have to pay the alternative compliance
payment
is that true
if there were insufficient wrecks to buy
then they would have to make our
alternative compliance payments yes if
if they still had an unfulfilled
compliance obligation but in in the most
i think in the most recent year
something over 75 percent of all the
compliance payments were handled by
wreck credits so so
and if you don't have to buy it so the
market doesn't have that demand
there's not the the whole point of
having the alternative compliance
payment was to put a cap so that price
couldn't rise too high well if you don't
have demand the price doesn't rise high
so nobody needs to make alternative
compliance payments which means that the
whole rps system which was supposedly
going to fund the renewable energy fund
through alternative compliance payments
doesn't have any money going in
that answers my question thank you so
much
representative pementel
thank you thank you mr chairman do you
have
the actual amount of
money that we're talking about that
the state is
sweeping from
producers and then giving away
to um
the uh utilities
i i believe the estimate and it's it's
an estimate we don't have you know the
the information that would be internal
to the to the state
uh
on the order of 10 million dollars so it
it in in the greater scheme of things no
10 million dollars isn't an enormous
amount of money but
the principle
that the state is seizing property and
handing it over to corporations to meet
their obligations thereby
denying the proper functioning of the
state's instituted market to create
funds to incentivize renewable energy
it's i'm sure it wasn't intended to work
this way but the result is that this
practice harms
creates real harm for our constituents
and it should be stopped
question if the state creates the
obligation in the first place
then
if the state provides
a way to satisfy that obligation
does that really harm anybody
yes and and under the um fallacious
arguments which uh
section at the back
um
actually
we probably didn't even put it here
because the whole first section was
about why it's property
renewable attributes are created when
you generate electricity every time you
generate a megawatt hour of energy you
create
one the the attributes of one megawatt
hour this this was the whole
i shouldn't i shouldn't try to talk off
the top of my head it's the reason i
have it written down so that i
don't trip over my 26
page
26. um
but that's where fallacious counter
arguments came in yes um
okay
the point is
that
up until the time that you had renewable
okay here's here's the where you're
having difficulty
up until the creation of the renewable
portfolio standard there wasn't an issue
of bundling and unbundling and
attributes being different from physical
attributes you know physical attributes
being different from renewable
attributes it was just electricity
but as soon as the state created this
mechanism they had to have a way to
track
the renewableness
and the only way and this is the way
that they designed that system
it doesn't create the property interest
the property interest is created and
that is clear in supreme court decisions
at apple court decisions and in state
court decisions this has been litigated
there is a property interest it is
created at the moment of the generation
of the electricity the renewable
attribute is just as much part of that
generation
as is the dancing electron
and when states have been trying to
incentivize
renewable energy to move us away from
fossil fuels and towards a more diverse
fuel portfolio this is a mechanism they
designed that doesn't mean the state
designs the property that doesn't mean
the state created the property interest
the property interest is created at the
moment the electricity is generated
okay further questions or comments
uh representative berezni
thank you mr chairman
i'm trying to understand whether
a renewable attribute
is property
when it's below one megawatt
on um on page 14
it says at the bottom
uh the gender the generator nevertheless
creates energy attributes with every
megawatt hour generated
and then on
on page 11
in the quote it says
renewable energy sources
the creation and state recognition of
rex did not result in an entirely new
commodity but in the splitting of a
pre-existing commodity
to me that sounds like you have to have
enough
r.a to be able to split it and then that
becomes the wreck so if you have less
than a rec amount of ra then it doesn't
no that the megawatt hour comes from the
designation of that as the as the wreck
so
the creation of the energy whether you
create one kilowatt with your system or
you create a million
kilowatts
kilowatt hours thank you
it doesn't matter it it's any energy
that you produce it's yours you and you
bought the equipment you invested your
money in it you gave it a place to work
and it functions
everything it produces is your property
the physical attributes of the
electricity is your property and the
renewableness the renewable attribute is
your property
what what what the the whole
rps and and wreck issue is a way of
creating
an artificial market
to generate funds
to incentivize renewable energy it had
this pernicious
and unrecognized
consequence
that it is a seizure of property
you you
it just it was not yeah i'm just
repeating myself i was i wasn't done yet
but okay on on page 13
it says
the middle bullet
that renewable energy source attributes
produced by generators that would quote
qualify to receive renewable energy
certificates so again that says that um
in order for the
ra to be valid it has to
um
be something that would qualify to to be
convertible into a a wreck no the the
generator
has to qualify um and
so if if your generator qualifies for
for the production of rex you can't get
a wreck unless you get to the megawatt
hour but but when
there is no minimal production level for
the creation of property
representative mcgee is recognized thank
you mr chairman i think i just i think
i'm here
hearing what it is that representative
brazhevny
is asking
which is
you're asking whether
the
the attribute exists below a megawatt
hour and i think the reason the
reference to the megawatt hour is in
uh in these slides the way that it is is
because that's the
quantity of energy
that is given a wreck
and so when they're discussing racks
they're discussing
megawatt hours
but remember the wreck is only the legal
representation of the attribute it's the
attribute that matters
right but if you if you don't have
enough
electricity to make up
the attribute for the attribute to make
up a wreck then do you still have
a wreck
or can it if it can't be converted into
a wreck because this says that it has to
be
that it has to a wreck is created by
dividing
the amount of energy that's considered
renewable
attribute energy so if you don't have
enough of that to be able to split it
into
rex
then the question is is it still the
same thing
the simple answer is yes it is the same
thing property is property whether you
have a little bit of it or you have a
lot of it
the legal representation of it
in a wreck using the denomination of a
megawatt hour is immaterial to the
question of whether it's property or not
if you have so little of it that it's
not
it's not the size of the unit of
measurement then do you still have maybe
this would help i have a very small
system it's a 6.7 kilowatt system
over the course of a year it produces
eight megawatts
hours eight megawatt hours
so i mean even a very very small system
will produce multiples
of megawatt hours
it's just a handy measure i i i think
you're
if i can help out mr chairman
just a little think of it as senator
harrington so you're buying gasoline
it's 3.50 a gallon that's the that's the
unit price of it so the megawatt hour is
the unit price for a wreck if you have
10 megawatt hours you get 10 wrecks i
believe if you have even less than a
megawatt hour you could get a half a
wreck it would just be valued at that
that's what you could sell but it's just
the unit of purchase and sale is the
megawatt hour just like a gallon is a
unit and purchases sale of uh of
gasoline you can have five thousand
gallons or you can have two gallons
maybe that helps
representative platt how do you contrast
what uh we are saying is a taking
with what the state does with the
checking and savings accounts that
haven't been active for quite a few
years they take it as abandoned property
and they confiscate it how do you
discriminate how do you distribute
between this and
i skipped over the abandoned property
slide because i didn't think it was that
useful but
you know we can go back to it it's slide
the mere fact that customer generators
do not bother registering and qualifying
their ras for sale into the new
hampshire rps compliance market does not
mean that they are unclaimed or
abandoned or lost
even if the swept heart renewable
attributes were hypothetically unclaimed
when the state seizes them they would
still not constitute abandoned property
under new hampshire law
the new hampshire abandoned property
statute provides that intangible
property must lie unclaimed for five
years before it becomes abandoned and
subject to state custody
wreck sweeping happens every year
yet the state seizes ras no later than
14 months after they are first created
moreover rsa 471c20 requires the state
to mail a written notice to an abandoned
property owner's last known address
informing the owner that it will take
custody of the property unless the owner
claims it before the state takes such
custody attempting to provide such
notice is also a constitutional
requirement under the 14th amendment's
due process clause
yet here in new hampshire and nowhere
else in the country
we make no effort whatsoever to notify
customer generators that are subject to
wreck sweeping
before seizing their renewable
attributes
who's next
you obviously haven't recognized me uh
representative callie pitts
um
well yeah
i have a
question on what
of this whole process
would be the fiscal impact
on
customers
in new hampshire
and the
second would be
that i don't understand why
i can sell a piece of property
and maybe that's our flaw to somebody
else sell my attributes sell my energy
back to the
company
and then get paid again for it
so
maybe that's something we have to tweak
but what is the the
impact on the customer now in one slide
that was meant you mentioned billions
and in
a statement you said 10 million
so what
in this especially in this climate
that we're in now not the physical
climate but the
psychological climate and the
the atmosphere we're in now
what would this do
to the price of energy
if the companies all of a sudden had to
start paying
compliance pains
and state i
has anyone figured that out
representative thomas is recognized
thank you
there is no direct answer to that
question however
i believe we did learn during the public
hearing
that
for one utility eversource
they estimate that
what they get
in this rex briefing is the equivalent
to approximately
one and a half to two million dollars
which would be which would be
if they didn't get it it would just be
added into their rate paying
projection which would increase
the cost of electricity to
everybody in the state granted it would
be a small amount but in my opinion any
anything we do now that increases
the cost of electricity to our to our
constituents is undesirable and wouldn't
be acceptable to me but that's that's
the only amount
that i i heard during public hearing
representative kelly pitts
i
just wanted to follow up
so i'm a customer and i'm generating
electricity
would i have to pay
extra
to
a company perhaps
to quantify
what
my attribute is worth because somehow
that's got to be measured
so
would i have to pay them to quantify
that
or is that just a free service
representative oxidant
a number of different questions out here
um so i'll probably start start with
what i can remember which is the most
recent one
uh i never said billions
um i i did say
millions
and i also said six cent the the
estimate is six cents on the ratepayers
monthly bill
again
you know we're talking about theft
we're talking about a deceptive process
we're talking about denying people their
property rights i don't think anyone in
the state of new hampshire would say oh
yeah i want to save my sixth cents on my
bill and let's let's steal people's
property without due process i that's
that's not something that we do
eversource may be getting 1.5 to 2
million but they are our big honcho they
are the big utility in the state
probably
all of the utilities are getting less
than
3.5 or 4 million altogether
the
double that with the the competitive
suppliers those are the corporations
that do absolutely nothing for you give
you nothing back and they're simply
saving money by not having to meet their
compliance payments so the state has
established a process it an obligation
in order to raise funds in order to
incentivize renewable energy this
process
is
cutting it off at the knees
but but that's secondary the primary
issue here is the one that it's
unconstitutional it's a property taking
and we are duty-bound when we become
cognizant of such a pernicious practice
to put an end to it
further comments
uh representative mick williams
um
i just want to commend you lee for this
in-depth presentation and the research
um that the department of energy had
requested referencing the specific
statutes um i think it's really helpful
to review the history and the statutes
to understand how all of this came
together and also looking at the legal
analysis i think it's helpful to
understand how this truly is property
and it belongs to our constituents and
we're doing the wrong thing right now
and we're in a position to make it right
so i want to commend you thank you i
really feel like this is a big deal for
for my constituents
okay it looks like we've pretty much
exhausted this subject
so
i would like to close the work session
on
house bill 1645 fn
and open a
executive session on said bill
and i recognize
representative berezni
uh thank you mr chairman i'd like to
make a motion to itl 1645
recognize
representative bernardi
i'll second that motion
it's been moved and seconded that we itl
hb
1645 fn point of clarification
yes point of clarification is this the
amendment or the
underlying bill
we made the
motion on the underlying bill thank you
so
we've had an extensive discussion do we
need further discussion on this subject
representative harrington
yeah i just uh i wanted to address some
of the issues that were brought up
previously here uh first from just from
a straight with practical matter
we have about 13 and a half percent
capacity factor has been attributed to
these solar panels uh that aren't needed
that's based on the iso new england
average
the problem with it is right now that's
just an average spread out over a whole
group of people and that is
swept up by the utilities or the uh
people that are selling the power
but if we would go
stop that practice as is proposed and
we're going to go back to giving it to
individual people how do you decide who
gets what because
doug could have a um system where his is
up and running and it's the exact same
size as mine and he's out there every
day it just gets dusty he's wiping it
down if it gets snow he's what he's
cleaning off the snow every day he's
working on it me mine works sometimes
sometimes it doesn't my inverter broke
i'll get around to fixing it when i get
back from vacation so since we both have
the same size system how do you decide
who's going to get these
uh that's that's one problem just from a
practical matter on it
so the the more basic one though on this
is that this concept that somehow
there's intrinsic value to rex
rex have no intrinsic value other than
that was granted to it by the renewable
portfolio standard
that's not right excuse me
city will be in order please
this member has a right to ha to speak
his his peace there's no value to them
whatsoever this concept that somehow
there was always renewable value to
energy implies that you know 50 years
ago when we were producing electricity
if you had a solar panel it was somehow
had renewable energy value it didn't
there's no renewable energy value other
than what's granted by the state
and the state has said we will give you
these pieces of paper which are
basically
government fiat they have no intrinsic
value other than that the state says
we're going to force people to buy these
in order to sell electricity in new
hampshire now to me without going i'm
not going to talk on here for too long
but let me just put it from a couple of
other things if you look at it
if we were to turn around to the
renewable portfolio standard and say
we're going to change the law we're
going to go from i don't know let's say
something is at 20 percent required uh
renewable for every electric supplier
we're going to drop that to 10 percent
according to the theory we just heard
that would be an unconstitutional taking
because we would make those wrecks worth
about half of what they are worth now
because you'd still be producing the
exact same type of electricity the exact
same amount but when you went out to
sell your wrecks you wouldn't get
anywhere near the price because people
wouldn't have to buy as many so that
would lower the price in the exact same
way so if we took that theoretically
kept going and put it to zero
the same thing if this is like saying
that once the rps law is passed the
state of new hampshire doesn't have the
power to get rid of it and we obviously
could repeal this law and there would be
no wrecks at all so you can produce all
the renewable power you want and it's
only going to produce electricity and
all you're going to sell it for is
electricity this is government created
value the person creates the generator
creates electricity which is actually a
commodity that's willing to be sold so i
think that's one thing you need to look
at the other thing the concept of these
big mean corporations from out of state
sweeping all this money and getting fat
off of it is just not realistic because
if they weren't using the money
to lower their rates the same way that
the utilities use it to lower their
rates then everyone would have default
service because there's no longer any
own generation so all of these companies
all the utilities bid into the same
market with the same conditions and if
eversource is taking which they have to
by law they take their when they get
swept they have to say i have to take
this off the rates and the other
utilities have to do the same thing if
some of these big mean corporations
don't do the same thing they would have
to offer higher prices and people
wouldn't be buying so that's another
fiction that's being put out there but
the real key thing is here just think
about the before there was a renewable
portfolio standard the wrecks weren't
worth anything because there were no
wrecks there was solar power there was
wind power there was all sorts of other
power but the only reason there's value
to iraq is because a law was created
that says there is and we can certainly
change that law to increase or decrease
the value of those wrecks including
making them worth totally nothing but
get rid of the renewable portfolio
standard
further discussion representative oxenam
thank you very much
the connecticut supreme court has held
that quote the renewable attribute of
the energy not the wreck not the legal
representation not the certificate the
renewable attribute of the energy
generated by renewable energy sources
is an inherent attribute of the energy
and therefore the creation and state
recognition of the certificates
rex
did not result in an entirely new
commodity but in the splitting of a
pre-existing commodity
the supreme court of the united states
i would appreciate it representative
harrington if you would give me the
respect due to
i've already heard your argument i don't
need to hear it again
had i mentioned previously the decision
by the united states supreme court in
the wheel of raider case
i i don't i don't believe that i did
and and the point there was exactly this
it was the sale of electricity
which occurred at a point in time where
the contract had been made before the
creation of the rps before the creation
of the legal fiction of these
certificates
and the question was what does it mean
now that we have a state-created rps
and the supreme court said
the renewable attributes of that energy
were there
all the time whenever it was generated
the wreck does not create the property
interest it only represents it
so
to follow up on that discussion a
renewable attribute
seems to be the the attribute seems to
be that the electricity is generated by
a renewable source that is the attribute
so if that is true then electricity
generated by a non-renewable
source would have a
non-renewable attribute
is that correct what makes a
renewable attribute worth any more than
a non-renewable attribute
it just seems to be a semantic
uh construction
something like a castle in the air that
has no real meaning
no real value
and
no real
definition if you can be subjected to a
10 000 a day penalty for violating the
ftc
there's something real of value here
this
um i'm sorry because you asked me three
questions in in the course of your
remarks and i'm having difficulty
separating them out
uh the the point
again is that the
you
originally
when when you somebody like me bought a
pv and generated electricity i could say
hey look
i'm i've got renewable energy
once
once you created this rps and this this
legal certificate which represents the
renewableness that is no longer
renewable energy that the fact this is
was what you were asking me that it was
tied to the equipment
that generated the electricity that's
what made it renewable
by law renewable attributes now
are
unbundled they are separated
and that is the property interest that
is at issue here it's not it is a real
interest it has monetary value
and it has real world value
no nobody discusses non-renewable
attributes because there is no
value to them
but it's a great value to a coal-powered
plant to be able to buy a wreck and say
oh we're supplying green energy we're
meeting our renewable compliance
program because we purchased this wreck
which means we own
the renewable attributes which were
stripped from the actual generator that
produced the energy i no longer have for
10 years i you know i invested money in
a renewable
array with the notion not of making
money at it i won't make money at it
i did it because i wanted to be
producing renewable energy and i wanted
to add to the total renewable energy in
the state and that property interest
has been
stolen from me and from anybody else
who
completely unbeknownst to them
has swept their renewable attributes
in some cases sold them
okay
i shouldn't i
let me take back that last four or five
words because that goes into a whole
different area that
and i i
didn't want to go there
intangible property as i discussed with
a
colleagues is is a difficult thing to
wrap your mind around it's like when you
create an invention
and get a patent for it
the invention and the patent are
separate things the patent merely
represents what you created your
intellectual effort
when you know intangible property is is
is hard to wrap your mind around but
it's real
and there are real world consequences
you can be held to a felony conviction
you can be ch held liable for ten
thousand dollars a day for deceptive
fraudulent practices if you represent
the manufactured product that your
factory produces with the renewable
generator that you invested in
because somebody unbeknownst to you has
swept the attributes and handed them
over to somebody else
otherwise it'd be double counting
you you only there's only so much
property
so are you saying that a kilowatt hour
of electricity that you generate with
your solar panels
is inherently more valuable than the
kilowatt hour i generate with my
electric generator
because there is a renewable compliance
wreck market there is a a financial
value there but there is also
an
intangible psychological
when i studied economics it was called a
um
psychic quasi rent
so yes psychic quasi rents my wife tells
me that that kilowatt hour of
electricity that we generate with our
generator is very valuable to her
when the washing machine won't work
because there's no electricity so
i would argue that
either kilowatt hour is inherently
worth the same amount and that seems to
be the crux of the issue here
remember the
value
that's attributed to a wreck
is
as representative harrington pointed out
a value that's created by government
it's an obligation that's created by
government but intrinsically that
kilowatt hour
when it's generated with a generator or
a solar panel
the electricity is essentially worth the
same because it'll do the same thing
which is work that's what we use
electricity to do we use electricity to
power machines to do work
and
this
renewable attribute
seems to be a
semantic construction that has no real
meaning and therefore has no real value
representative mcgee thank you mr
chairman
my my my um we're going around the world
here
i'd just like to bring it back if i
could to
i think the intent of the bill
[Music]
okay
i wanted to clarify something that i
heard uh when representative harrington
spoke earlier he made several points but
he started out with saying you know if
if these wrecks don't get swept and get
used the way they're being used
currently
and they have to go back to people but i
clean my you know i don't clean my array
and this guy cleans his right how do you
figure it out he made it sound all so
confusing
all the bill is saying is you don't get
to take my property it doesn't say
what happens after that it doesn't say
anybody has to collect it and do the
math and redistribute it none of that
happens you just keep your own property
you do with what you want
you do what you want with it right so
there is no there is no redistribution
there is no state involvement it repeals
the idea of taking it from a person
who's generating it and using their
asset for something else and then
the other thing that i think should be
just stated about the attribute we have
differences of opinion on this committee
as to whether the science is correct and
the environmental
impacts of what's going on with our
energy use
should be valued or there should be
incentives for us to try and clean up
the way we power our society
that's what the attribute is valued it
for that's what the rps is for that's
why states all over the country and
countries all over the world are trying
to figure out ways
to
create price points that support
an energy market that values
uh energy that is better for the
environment that's all
all right i'm going to suggest that we
uh
call the question here mr representative
harrington yeah i just like to respond
very quickly because of what she did
question something i said and maybe she
misunderstood me
it sounds like what you're saying is the
intent of the bill
is to simply not allow the utilities or
the electric suppliers to sweep the
wrecks but that nobody else would get
them so as far as the the uh net
generated net meter generators that
don't have the more expensive metering
equipment they would be in the exact
same situation they are now they're not
going to get another dime because
they're not going to get any wrecks the
wrecks are just not going to go to the
utilities and go to the electric
suppliers so of course that'll have to
result in higher rates
my thought was i thought what they was
being proposed was that somehow the
wreck would not be swept but they would
be returned to the people who generate
the power and my question is if you
don't know how much somebody generates
how do you distribute the power up to
all the individual solar solar producers
that was what i was referring to right
and i said you wouldn't have to so you
would you wouldn't just simply they
wouldn't get anything then
they'd be no better off than they are
now they simply would be but their
property wouldn't be taken by somebody
else they wouldn't have any problems
without their knowledge
okay so let's not have a debate without
raising one's hand okay so
uh
we've gone around and around on this
question i think it's time to call the
question
and uh
have a vote on this bill so that we can
move on it's now almost quarter past
three and we still have another bill to
address we have been discussing the
amendment and not the bill which we are
to vote
on the motion on the floor is itl on
house bill 1645 there is no motion on
the floor for an amendment so
mr clerk would you call the role on the
question of itl on hb 1645
i i have a parliamentary question what
is your i've been sitting on it all day
if a bill is itl
then it is not open to amendment is that
correct
because you have nothing to amend that
is correct so this would also kill the
amendment correct correct this action
correct thank you
it would preclude the amendment it
wouldn't kill it which is precluded yes
all right so mr clerk please call the
roll on the question of itl on hb 1645.
mike's iran please turn your microsoft
there's a maximum of five that i think
is allowed
all right um representative thomas yes
representative harrington yes
representing the otter yes
representative bernard yes
representative platfords yes represent
berezni yes represent bernardi yes
of cambrils yes represent pleasure yes
representative white yes representative
yes representative massa miller no
representative kelly pitts
representative mann no
representative oxnam no representative
horrigan no representative mcgee no
representative mcwilliams no
representative phillips no
representative pimentel
representative pasha
and the chair yes 12 to 10.
representative representative oxenam
you'll be writing the minority report
okay i think you have plenty of material
to work with yes the difficulty is
cutting it down
okay so
representative oxygen
all right we have one more bill to do so
i'll close the pub the exec session on
hb 1645
and we will open
an ex an executive session on house bill
and on this bill i will recognize
representative harrington for a motion
mr chairman i move ought to pass on hb
representative knotter is recognized i
second the motion
it's moved and seconded that hb
1629 to be ruled ought to pass
is their
discussion representative harrington
thank you mr chairman this is sort of a
follow-up to the bill we looked at
before it goes a little bit one step
further in trying to adjust the false
service rate i'm not going to try to be
too long and overboring but default
service rate has a lot of complications
into it and it's as fast as i can do it
i will do it basically the utility sets
out and says we have a load profile
we're gonna we're gonna have we need a
supplier for a certain percentage of our
power for a certain percentage of time
they put up that large profile out it
goes to a bunch of suppliers the
suppliers review that they have to of
course negotiate with actual generators
or maybe even an interim supplier and
they come up with a proposal where
they're going to get so much power from
this uh plant and so much power from
that plant they have to have reserves
and capacity backups because as i
mentioned earlier about 40 of the total
cost of default service is the
contingency to make sure you can always
match uh the supply with the demand
so then these you those companies come
up with a proposal they submit it to the
utility the utility then turns around
and has to review these and decide which
one to pick it picks one now based built
into that price there's going to be the
cost associated with the supplier for
not only acquiring the power but the big
thing is that risk factor which i say
could be up to 40 percent for making
sure he can always match they also have
their just administrative costs as well
as of course they're trying to make a
profit or they wouldn't be doing this
all of that is built into the price that
they submit to the to the utility then
the utility has to take that review
those pick one out obviously there's
cost involved it's always a pass-through
for the utility there's no profits on
this side on this
and then they have to take it to the puc
and get the contract approved and then
in the process of that built into that
contract of course is the monitoring by
both the utility and the supplier 24 7
to always make sure you have enough uh
supply to match demand that's all in
default service as well as such things
as we talked about earlier the renewable
portfolios uh standard requirements
where the utility has to pay that as
well there's also um
the forward capacity market which each
supplier is charged a certain fee for
and that has to be all collected through
default service so there's a very large
amount of costs
more than 50 percent of default service
is not a cost
that the
net metering supplier ever sees they
just don't see this because they're not
involved in all this contract
negotiation they have no obligation to
provide any electricity at any time
which you have to understand is probably
the biggest single factor the utility is
out there saying we have to be there 24
7 all the time to supply whatever the
load is
where if you're a net metering customer
you can turn on or turn off whenever you
want there's no repercussions there's no
penalties any other type of generator
you you bit into the market if you don't
make your uh you don't supply that
amount of power you're gonna have to buy
it from somebody else but there's no
risk involved no risk factor whatsoever
with the net metering customers so they
don't see any of these charges and
there's really no reason to pay them for
them uh and as far as the renewable
portfolio standard we already discussed
that that was a double payment issue so
i'll just leave it go with that
thank you
further discussion on
house bill 1629 representative mcgee
thank you mr chairman
yep this is the bill that i started to
go off on about a little while ago
because i i actually think that this
this bill um is the bill that i was
thinking of when i was saying that we
are
uh rate setting from the house which we
really have no expertise on there are
lots of things you can throw out there
and you can look at them
from multiple perspectives you can say
they're you know they don't have any of
these costs well they have other costs
you're not counting you know
it's it's a completely arbitrary
approach at trying to lower the value of
uh net metering
but i made a note when we had the
hearing
that default service providers go out to
bid for service and that
passing this bill could lead to a failed
default service auctions that's that was
testimony that we had
this is a huge departure again this is
this is rate setting and
we have talked again and again about the
fact that the value of distributed
energy resources is not something we
have in hand and so for us to make this
determination
and decide that we're gonna we're gonna
lower the value of this without knowing
what the value is because we have a
study that is ready to come in the
spring
is very irresponsible it's it's not
it doesn't make sense for uh
for a policy-making body
to arbitrarily
set rates for an entire segment of you
know the energy sector
without the knowledge of whether we're
doing the right thing we can we can all
argue back and forth i'm doing it right
you're doing it right but we don't know
and that much i do know
so i i would ask that we not vote ought
to pass on this because it's it's just a
bad bill
representative platt yes this former
rate center for public service new
hampshire has a question for
representative harrington all the margin
that's built into default service other
than the cost of wholesale electricity
such as risk
mitigation because they don't know what
they're getting at any time
all the compliance
for rps and all that stuff is
unavoidable in any
i don't see any way it can possibly be
avoidable by putting in the default
service but again those are costs and
the key thing here those are costs that
are not seen by the uh net metering if
people want to talk about that net
metering has some other intrinsic value
we should pay them for that's fine let's
figure out what that is and we can set a
value on it but let's not pay them for
cost that they never see and that's what
we're doing right now they don't
negotiate contracts they don't have any
risk premium which is huge because they
have no risk they can run when they want
if they don't want to run they don't
have to without any penalties they don't
see any of these costs why should we pay
them for it
thank you i would remind the members
that
this is not rate setting we're talking
about public policy here the legislature
decides public policy
net metering is essentially a
incentive
with a subsidy
to try to encourage more solar energy
that was a public policy choice
and the legislature gets to decide how
much of its money it wants how much of
the public's money should be invested
in that public policy
this bill
is saying
that we think
that the amount of money that's invested
into this
public policy this net metering policy
should be
what's
intrinsically the value of the
electricity
not what's intrinsically the value of a
utility company's
rfp for default service which includes a
lot of things
beyond
simply the electricity
now if the puc was conducting
a rate setting
adjudicative
session on net metering
it likely would determine that avoided
cost
is the appropriate value of net metering
and
there have been
several lawsuits that have argued for
that that have not gone forward because
of jurisdictional issues but
there has been indication in a lot of
legal journals
that
barring those jurisdictional problems
it's likely that net metering costs
would be set at avoided cost
perpa for example which was one of the
first renewable energy laws passed in
this country uses avoided costs as the
appropriate
rate if you will for incentivizing
renewable energy
so i think it's perfectly appropriate
for us to
set in new hampshire state law
that the appropriate compensation for
this public policy should be the value
of the electricity
that is produced and returned to the
grid
representative platt i would say we're
overpaying even at the voted cost
because it doesn't have the attributes
of of the people supplying the energy
from the from the from uh through isil
new england because it could be there
could not be there
and the the generators are putting it in
the market have to guarantee that
they're there or they pay otherwise
correct
uh representative mann did you have a
comment oh
i wanted to agree with the latter
comment oh okay
representative mcgee yeah thank you mr
chairman
um i agree with you that the legislature
has the responsibility and the right to
uh determine what what we're paying what
we're uh what we're allotting in terms
of incentives and all that
i think when we had testimony what we
heard was that
uh
when
when deregulation first went in
and they looked at how to set these
rates they determined that the default
service rate would be about right
because there were other costs not the
same costs as
as the utilities or the default service
providers but there would be other costs
and so they they they did the rough
justice thing again right they used this
and we
did we discussed in that hearing the
fact that we were waiting for the value
of distributed energy
uh study the vd the vder study in order
to decide where we go from here is it
more valuable than we think is it less
valuable than we think and what we're
doing with this bill is we're
circumventing having the information to
make an informed decision and we're
saying
ideologically we believe x and so that's
what we're gonna do
and i just think it's it what it is is
disruptive to the market and to people
who are trying to invest in cleaner
energy solutions and so it's like the
state saying basically we're not
interested in helping the environment
we've decided to go in a different
direction and i i just really strongly
agree with that as an opinion
and i i don't think that that's what
we're here for
um it seems arbitrary to just pick this
and say we're sticking with this when we
have no idea how it's going to play
itself out in the market
but it certainly will act as a
disincentive and so it it feels like
that's what the objective is here
actually
it's not ideological it's logical if a
commodity on the market is worth worth
let's say a nickel
then why would you pay someone a nickel
plus another nickel for that same
commodity that's what this
the net service net default service
essentially does it says we'll give you
a nickel for the electricity and we'll
pay another nickel
but that's not
logical
well it doesn't it doesn't
representative
logic doesn't always apply in the
legislature and i've learned that over
25 years
i was here when we did the direct
deregulation and we set the default
rates
we didn't do that in 20 minutes we
didn't do that in one hearing and oh
let's just arbitrarily fix it we did
that over weeks and months
and very carefully
and
my belief in this is that
this
is not the time
to change something it may be it may
need to be tweaked i agree it was many
years ago that we did this
but this is not the time
we need to incentivize
more of this energy and we know that
i think every one of us knows that that
we need to get off
of gradually get off of fossil fuels to
a bigger extent than we are now
and to fix this
again arbitrarily to save
our customers in general
a few pennies
on their electric bill
is not the right move right now if we
were going to save millions
by cutting this and we were going to say
your bill is going to be cut by twenty
dollars a month because we think it's
gonna go up by thirty dollars a month
then i'd say let's do it but i don't
think that's the case and i think this
is a disincentive so i really believe
that this bill instead of
going forward needs to be looked at more
carefully and by people have more
expertise
than me
or i'm gonna say generally than i
believe is around this table because our
expertise was from before
this is now so i think we really need to
delve into this subject and delve into
it carefully
that's my two cents
representative platt
i appreciate representative callie
pitt's position with respect to what she
thinks
might be valuable but what she
attributes that to me that's not
necessarily true i think the renewable
energy quite frankly is is no more
valuable than any other energy and i
think the climate change stuff is a
bunch of crap
representative plat uh
it's scientifically unprovable i don't
believe i didn't say one word was
commenting about the language not not
the contention uh which is an opinion
you hold and you're you're entitled to
that but please refrain from using
language that could be offensive
representative kelly pittsburgh i did
not say one word about climate change
what i'm thinking about is right now our
supply of electricity and our
supply of fossil fuels we know that's in
jeopardy every day
so that's what i said i didn't say one
word about climate change pro or con you
can read into that
and i know that what i'm going on is
from the past and we need to get into
the now
and i think we again need to look at
expertise to do that because the clock
is running out
that's no excuse to do things
willy-nilly or
on the on the fly
one of the questions that
confronts our committee quite frequently
and will confront it again
once we start receiving bills from the
senate during this session
is the expansion of net metering
and one of the reasons i believe that
there is a reluctance to expand neck
metering is because of the potential
high cost of such expansion
a bill like this one
which would set
the value of
net metered electricity to the same
value as
electricity generated in other
with by other sources
is that it would allow the expansion of
net metering without a worry about a
rapid expansion in costs
so that's another reason to support this
bill is if you want
for example the university of new
hampshire to be included in the
municipal group host net metering
program that we passed last year in hb
then you need to set
the rate for net metering at a rate that
won't greatly expand costs otherwise
that may never happen that expansion of
net reading may never happen
so that's another consideration
i think we've talked this uh through
pretty thoroughly except representative
oxenoum has another thought thank you
very much
thank you very much i i haven't spoken
on this issue
this bill would allow utilities to
grossly overcharge customer generators
for default service
yeah
the value
of
distributed local generation is that it
reduces load
the big charge on what we pay for energy
is at the coincident peak
this is load reduction
it we don't take power from the grid
because we're producing it locally
the last entry into the market sets the
price for all the entrants in the market
so the highest cost you cut out the
highest cost producer you substantially
reduce costs
that's a value
there are others
um and i know everybody wants me to to
just but i i'll leave it at that
load reduction is an enormous value
and the money
that the reason that you are over
charging for default service is that
these things transmission charges there
are no transmission charges for customer
generators so
it's the these your your
the the utility charges in the default
service rate for things that customer
generators don't
get from them they're paying for a
service they don't get
and they are not being paid for value
they provide
thank you
peak demand changes all the time and
it's incredibly hard to predict when it
will happen
so
to say that intermittent generation can
somehow reduce peak demand
is
a falsehood because you can't predict
when that's going to happen
that is not a falsehood and i can get
you the textual information that
demonstrates its validity it's a logical
falsehood there may be text out there
that asserts that it's not a falsehood
but it's a logical falsehood for the
following reason if you'll let me
explain
if it's intermittent if it's not
happening all the time
then how can it catch the peak when the
peak happens because the peak you can't
predict when that's going to happen
green power in vermont did this last
year and please don't interrupt please
let me finish
if you can't predict when the peak is
going to happen
and you're not operating
24 7 then your chances of catching the
peak
are
less slim
less certainly
therefore
you can't really say that that
is load reduction because it may not be
operating at the time that the peak
occurs and so it's not reducing
the peak at all
and so intermittent load reduction is
really not load reduction
and i think the vder study will show
that
mr chairman
representative harrington quickly
comment on that just one thing we can
talk about load reduction in peak we can
make some pretty
substantial statements about load
reduction we know for example load the
load peak in new england or new
hampshire
is in november december january in most
likely february going to be sometime
after five o'clock when people come home
and they're all cranking up their lights
and stoves and everything else and we
can also be assured that at some time
after five o'clock we're getting almost
nothing out of solar panels in fact
sometimes it's absolutely zero so i i
don't want to interrupt but we're going
to be losing one of our subs who has
another meeting to go off to so i was
wondering if we could call the vote i'm
sorry
okay
i i'm i'm amenable to that let's call
the question mr clerk
please call the roll on the question of
ita of um
not to pass rather on house bill
1629 representative thomas
yes representative harrington yes
representative notter yes representative
yes representative pled votes yes
representative berezni yes
representative bernardi
representative campbell's yes
representative pleasure yes
representative white yes representative
yes represent massimo vs messimilla no
okay
oh yeah but i had it misspelled and i
had to fix it
yeah a representative kelly pitts
representative mann no
no i heard you i just had to fix a
previous error
representative oxnam no representative
horrigan no
mcgee no representative mick williams no
representative heck and phillips no
representative pen patel no
representative uh
partial
and the chair
yes 12 10.
representative mcgee who will write the
minority report
representative mcgee will write the
okay with that we're going to close the
executive session on house bill
1629 i have some information from you
some late breaking information
on monday march 7th we're going to
resume the public hearing
on house bill 1459
and i have just been informed a few
minutes ago
that the arborist from eversource will
be here at 11 a.m to give us a
presentation on how
eversource does vegetation management in
the state so that could be a very
interesting
presentation i'm told he's a very
compelling speaker and he gives this
presentation
around the state i guess
and so it's likely to be
a very good presentation so we'll have
our
continuation of the public hearing on
1459 starting at 10.
we will complete that at 9 45.
we will execute at 9 45.
10 45 brother 10 45.
and
then we will have the presentation at 11
o'clock
so that is our schedule for next week
and so we will send you see you on
monday the 7th and i'll remind you all
that we have a house session on thursday
the 10th
and with that i thank you all for your
hard work today we had some really good
stimulating discussions
and uh enjoyed it immensely i hope you
did too and we'll see you all next week
for the three bills that i'm doing but
i'm going to be rewriting
the second one at least successing 29 so
i'll set they're all in one page
i've kept them short so i'll just
resubmit the whole thing
oh
um
terrible
next thursday it's nine next wednesday
wednesday i mean right it's before the
house the day before at nine i think
it's
nine or ten i know they'll probably put
out another
stuff down
is
you